nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 9
juillet 180 euros net en plus par mois
pour les soignants c'est ce qu'il
ressort du projet d'accord négocié par
les représentants du personnel
hospitalier et le gouvernement la nuit
dernière dans le cadre du ségur de la
santé le texte doit être validé par les
syndicats avant lundi pas suffisant pour
certains collective quant aux médecins
et ont carrément claqué la porte des
négociations marathon social pour le
premier ministre 14 organisations
syndicales et patronales sont reçus à
matignon entre aujourd'hui et demain
au menu deux dossiers brûlants
l'application de la réforme du chômage
et la très contestée réforme des
retraites
jean cassette veut les régler à court
terme de leur cô té lé syndicat à
pencher pour un report
[Musique]
faudra-t-il travailler plus pour
reconstruire l'économie laminé par
locaux vides 19 au fil de ses
interventions emmanuel macron semble
elle est en ce sens mais n'y at-il pas
un paradoxe a demandé aux français de
travailler plus alors que le chômage
monte en flèche
une question sur laquelle l'économiste
jacques sapir reviendra tout à l'heure
dans son édito échos bras de fer entre
donald trump et des universités
américaines le président américain s'en
est pris avec virulence aux facultés qui
dispenseront leurs cours en ligne la
rentrée en raison de l'épidémie de
coronavirus hier le pays à passer le cap
des 3 millions de contaminations et
déplore plus de 130000 mort du co vite
on est
[Musique]
c'est un accord au forceps syndicats
hospitaliers et gouvernement ont conclu
un compromis hier dans les nuits dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé les détails
de ce projet d'accord avec notre
reporter bassin chebbi au ministère de
la santé si les contours du plan massif
en faveur de l'hôpital sont désormais
arrêter cela ne plaît pas à tout le
monde une dizaine d'un tiers des
hôpitaux de paris se sont donné
rendez-vous aujourd'hui devant le
ministère de la santé pour contester les
propositions du gouvernement en faveur
de l'hôpital public je vous propose est
d'écouter quelques réactions alors cette
mobilisation l'a décidé la semaine
dernière suite aux premières annonces
qui ont été faites par le ministre
concernant les internes qui était bien
en deçà de ce qu'on a ce qu'on espérait
et donc l'idée c'est de avant la fin des
négociations de montrer que tout ce
qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on a fait
pendant le vide il faut que ce soit
valorisée et notamment valoriser par une
alimentation de 300 euros net par mois
et ce qui nous a été proposé ses 150
euros brut par mois et que pour les
premières années l'internât ce qui peut
et historique c'est la tenue d'un ségur
de la santé et des enveloppes allouées
qui qui font que continuer à tomber et
qui essaye d'être plus essentielle
sensationnaliste les unes que les autres
mais là pour le moment en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les internes en médecine de
france là pour le moment nos attentes
elles sont préparées sont pas remplies
moi ce que j'en pense c'est que pendant
que vit on a entendu beaucoup de choses
et je pense que certains d'entre nous un
certain espoir qu'on allait enfin être
écoutés que là aujourd'hui on fait
encore une fois on nous manque de
respect
nous proposons par exemple la révélation
des gardes
une réalisation qui est vraiment minime
qui a moins de 1 euros brut de l'heure
en plus pour moi c'est un manque de
respect après plus de six semaines de
négociations entre le gouvernement et
les syndicats dans le cadre de ce c'est
dur pour la santé hier un projet
d'accord a été présenté mettant sur la
table une enveloppe de 7 5 milliards
d'euros une enveloppe qui a été jugé
historique par le ministère de la santé
je vous rappelle que ce projet prévoit
une revalorisation socle de 180 euros
nets par mois pour le personnel
hospitalier hors médecins
une augmentation qui se fera en deux
temps à savoir 90 euros net par mois à
partir du 1er septembre prochain puis 90
euros nets à partir de mars prochain
ce projet prévoit également plus de
quinze mille nouvelles embauches
les syndicats ont jusqu'au 13 juillet
prochain pour donner leur accord
concernant cette proposition du
gouvernement et pour en parler
rachid digoit infirmiers chu chalon sur
saône et président du collectif inter
blocs dont soit rachid y voit merci
d'être avec nous 180 euros en plus pour
les soignants c'est un effort du côté du
gouvernement vous en vouliez 300 quelle
est votre réaction aujourd'hui une
avancée quand même pour vous non du tout
n'est on est très loin du compte un le
socle de départ étaient des 300 euros
pour tous et et 180 euros pour nous
c'est un échec un échec du gouvernement
est un échec de ceux qui sont parties
aux négociations à nous représenter donc
on est on est très en colère les tous
les collègues issus de la base je peux
vous dire qu'il ya des réactions qui
sont unanimes et on est on est très très
en colère ce soir alors 15000 personnel
devrait également être embauché dans
dans les hôpitaux c'est une avancée elle
qui vous paraît pour le coup il
acceptable
c'est toujours pareil vous savez pour
pour embaucher deux personnes il faut
être attractif au niveau salaire donc
vous pouvez proposer des embauches si
derrière il ya des conditions des
conditions de travail qui sont
déplorables et des salaires qui sont qui
sont misérables
vous pouvez toujours attendre que les
collègues arrivent dans au niveau des
hôpitaux pour travailler alors vous
dites
vous êtes très en colère comment
imaginez vous la suite des négociations
parce que voilà on le sent le
gouvernement essayait de faire un effort
a rajouté un peu plus d'un milliard
que va-t-il se passer maintenant vous
maintenez la mobilisation bien sûr et
plus que jamais on va maintenir la
mobilisation et je pense que la rentrée
va être très très compliqué pour le
gouvernement il ya la colère et la
colère monte ça va être aussi très
compliqué je pense pour certains
syndicats qui sont partis nous
représenter et qui qui se satisfont de
cette avancée qui n'en est pas une pour
nous clairement il y a quand même eu un
accord même s'il a été à l'arraché puis
au forceps ça veut dire qu'il ya une
partie quand même de du personnel qui
est d'accord qui est satisfaite
bah oui c'est ce que je faisais à
certains syndicats qui sont qui sont
heureux de cette avancée ne se sont pas
forcément des syndicats représentatifs
et en tout cas pas représentatifs de la
base comme comme on peut l'être sont des
gens qui sont partis négocier pour nous
et je pense que leur base leur base à
eux va être très en colère avaient alors
que sa remontée ce qu'il faut pour bien
qu'on comprenne nous finalement
téléspectateurs spectateurs de ces
négociations
combien d'entre vous sont finalement
d'accord et qu'on vient justement de
syndicats ne le sont pas est ce que
c'est représentatif vraiment bas en tout
cas a priori nous les causes qu'on a
comme écossais qu'il ya une majorité des
syndicats qui sont d'accord il a
quelques uns qui vont pas signer je
pense et j'espère en tout cas qu'ils
vont pas signer qui vont écouter les
gens du terrain comme nous voilà après
on continue on va continuer la lutte
assez clair et je pense que ça va être
très compliqué à la rentrée comme je
vous disais également aussi pour ces
syndicats qui sont partis non
représentés sans nous défendre vraiment
puisque cette crise comme id qu'on a
traversé je peux vous dire que après
tout ce qu'on a vécu je peux vous dire
qu'on a la rage on aurait on aurait
défendu on aurait défendu nos nos
métiers comme il se doit mais
aujourd'hui ces gens là je pense qu'il
n'était pas sur le terrain au moment du
comité je pense que c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont pas à taper du
poing sur la table assez fort pour avoir
ne serait-ce que le socle commun des 300
euros pour tous
clairement vous ne craignez pas
aujourd'hui une division justement de
l'unité syndicale qui va faiblir
vos revendications après honnêtement au
niveau syndical yahia turu de la
division à chacun c'est un peu de la
politique chacun prêche pour sa paroisse
donc c'est le gouvernement s'en est bien
servi aussi je pense au niveau des
négociations
donc aujourd'hui ça nous issues de la
base et du terrain de faire remonter
cette colère et de et de enfin se faire
représenter comme il se doit et c'est
vrai que nous on n'a pas été invité aux
ségur en tant que collectif et et
organisations on a même été décriée par
certaines organisations syndicales qui
ont dit qu'on n'avait pas notre place
aujourd'hui on voit que ils nous ont pas
représenter correctement et je peux vous
dire qu'à la rentrée ça va être
compliqué pour eux quand vous dites ça
va être compliqué pour eux concrètement
que va t-il se passer
bon il ya une perte de confiance totale
avec eux je pense a donc ça va je sais
pas il va falloir trouver d'autres
moyens peut-être de se mobiliser sans
enjeu à voir on va on va voir on va on
va plancher cet été et puis on va
ressortir je pense quelque chose à la
rentrée alors olivier ferrand lui
souligner la qualité des échanges menés
avec les syndicats et rappelé son
souhait d'aboutir à un accord il s'agit
d'un projet d'accord historique a
précisé l'entourage du ministre le
maintien d'olivier verrons au
gouvernement quelle est votre réaction
will bratt façon c'est voilà ces
politiques politique qui se connaissent
tous entre eux donc bah voilà 6,6 à
monsieur vers ans était parti c'est à ce
moment là ça aurait été vraiment un
signal fort pour nous en tant que
soigneur qu'on était en pleine
négociation du c ur donc sa place y voit
là ils l'ont laissé pour le moment on
verra on verra par la suite
merci beaucoup rachid digoit d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france jean
castex ne perd pas de temps entre
aujourd'hui et demain vont défiler à
matignon syndicats et patronat quatorze
rencontres au total début des entretiens
ce matin 8h30 avec laurent berger de la
cfdt
et si jean cassaigne peut reprendre les
négociations sur la réforme des
retraites ce n'est pas forcément le cas
les syndicats écouter ses réactions en
prise à la sortie de matignon on lui a
remis nos propositions sur l'emploi des
jeunes sur l'emploi sur le plan de
relance avec une volonté
de concertation on a redit qu on voulait
une concertation d'ailleurs qui associe
et le ministère du travail et le
ministère de l'économie et qu'on
souhaitait un plan de relance qui soient
annoncées à la fin à la fin août début
septembre qu'on voulait il participe et
on lui a fait des propositions au terme
de deux de transition écologique de
l'emploi des jeunes il ya la transition
écologique
bref on n'était pas tellement non plus
sur le fond on était plutôt sur la
méthode
là on a fait un échange aujourd'hui on
se revoit si j'ai bien compris le 17 ans
multilatérales ont valu précisé ce qu'on
lui a dit rapidement ce matin le régime
la cgt à une journée expliqué en long en
large et en travers
nous avons débattu avec les ministres
sur des chaînes de radio de télé
publiquement nous n'avons jamais été
contredit jamais mis en difficulté et le
gouvernement n'a jamais réussi à
expliquer et à convaincre de l'intérêt
du bien fondé de son projet donc notre
position n'a pas changé nous n'en
voulons pas et nous n'en voudront pas
donc on peut saluer un ton très direct
très franches à dire presque rugbyman
dans le fait de passer un peu les
finalement les préliminaires on s'est
dit les choses
il ya une volonté de dialoguer il ya une
volonté de concerter sur le calendrier
sur les sujets je l'avais entendu dire
par lesdits responsabilité et donc
juridique qui serait irresponsable de ne
pas traiter les questions d'emploi et
des bas salaires dans la période et que
c'était le sujet essentiel dans la
période et les salariés constatent que
plus le gouvernement donne de l'argent
aux entreprises
plus il ya de licenciement et donc c'est
ça qu'il fallait rectifier bon j'ai
trouvé que le premier ministre était
attentif à nos propos maintenant comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire c'était
union pour faire connaissance pour
échanger sur les sujets d'actualité
en tout cas de notre actualité on verra
on jugera aux actes est à noter que la
cgt qui a appelé à une journée de
manifestations et de grève le 17
septembre prochain une heure à peine
après cette réunion
pour en parler nous sommes avec nicolas
vidal directeur de la publication putsch
médias à ses côtés henri sterdyniak
économiste à l'ofce monde des
économistes atterrés bonsoir à tous les
deux merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france c'est un avertissement que
l'once les syndicats ou nouveau premier
ministre henri sterdyniak
mais les syndicats surpris il sait
grandes préoccupations des travailleurs
actuellement emploi un certain nombre de
plans sociaux il ya le problème des huit
cent mille jeunes qui vont arriver sur
le marché du travail dgt s'attendait à
ce qu'on parle de l'emploi se retrouve
devant un premier ministre qui leur
parle des retraites sujet qui n'est
absolument pas d'actualité actuellement
on a un premier ministre qui essaie
d'utiliser le déficit des retraites due
à la crise pour faire passer des mesures
qui sont absolument pas d'actualité
c'est pas quand il ya un grand problème
de l'emploi pour les jeunes qu'on va
dire qu'on va faire travailler les 62 64
ans donc naturellement les syndicats
nous ne pouvaient pas s'entendre avec ce
premier ministre après l'épidémie de
coronavirus reprendre le dossier
explosif de la réforme des retraites
c'est ce que les français attendent
selon vous nicolas vidal ah oui ils sont
les populations les français d'avoir
cette réforme de retraites on l'avait vu
pendant six mois
la réalité c'est que emmanuel macron
s'est débarrassé de leur fille pour le
sait tous mais il a nommé finalement ce
que j'appellerais un super directeur de
cabinet un emmanuel macron et jean
castex donc à ce côté vous savez c'est
fanny un peuple autophobie cet accent
peu gersois ce côté enraciné ce côté
populaire ce côté hommes des territoires
jean plastique faut pas l'oublier
comme haut fonctionnaire magistrat à la
cour des comptes donc côté d'ailleurs le
boss du medef a parlé du côté rugbyman
de jean castex mais moi je pense que ce
n'est pas un pré ministre emmanuel nacro
il a nommé quelqu'un qui va pouvoir
mettre en place cette réforme des
retraites
c'est une fausse caution populaire jean
castex d'ailleurs je m'étonne toujours
qu'il n'y a toujours pas eu de discours
de politique générale jean castex alors
que les débats l'assemblée ont repris
leur gouvernement donc non je crois pas
que les français attendent vraiment la
réforme des retraites et donc mais une
langue à ce texte et avec emmanuel
m'apprend remède la table est couvert
tous et tout est prêt pour repartir
finalement dans un truc qui va être
intenable ramon à mon sens dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines alors il n'y a pas eu de
discours de politique générale mais tout
de même jean castets seul a précisé un
gouvernement de combat avec sait
davantage sur les territoires ça veut
dire quoi concrètement
henri sterdyniak vous l'économiste vous
lisez entre les lignes vous vous
attendez à quoi nous attend pas s'attend
pas à grand chose à dire que c'est un
gouvernement de combat ça ne donne pas
beaucoup d'informations à tous les
gouvernements peuvent prétendre et des
gouvernements de combat en voit rarement
un premier ministre dire je suis là pour
ne rien faire le problème c'est quoi
faire naître une situation économique
difficile il faut absolument relancer il
faut fournir des emplois aux jeunes et
fournir des emplois aux jeunes ça doit
se faire en même temps avec la
transition écologique
donc il faut des emplois dans la
transition écologique dans la rénovation
des vosges mort dans les énergies
renouvelables dans les soins aux encore
aux bébés rideau personnes âgées
donc il ya du boulot le risque c'est que
le gouvernement nous propose cette
direction et parler maintenant des
réformes des aides de la forme des
retraites
c'est une provocation parce que on voit
pas qui va faire est ce qu'il va dire
aux retraités on diminue les retraites
est ce qu'il va dire aux 62 64 ans
rester au travail détriment de vos
enfants et vous
petits enfants c'est parfaitement
ridicule un d'autre part on a vu que la
réforme des retraites aux hedge des tas
de questions au niveau des proches au
niveau d'un certain nombre de métiers
pénibles d'acerta muet et d'un certain
également des non salariés
on voit pas perdre encore un an à
discuter de ça alors que on va avoir un
taux de chômage qui va dépasser les 12 %
nicolas vidal c'était maladroit de
revenir avec cette réforme des retraites
dans le même temps c'est le cas de le
dire on aurait reproché au gouvernement
de ne pas suivre sa ligne non parce que
la réforme des retraites il a réformé
merde emmanuel macron au poisson il faut
absolument qu'ils la passent et une
nouvelle fois je lui ai dit plusieurs
fois sur votre antenne si on la réforme
des retraites on peut pas la voir si on
ne voit pas ce qui se passe à bruxelles
l'union européenne
je rappelle toujours les grandes
orientations de politique économique qui
depuis 2010 lui demande un moment donné
de pouvoir mettre en place dans ces pays
les pays famille vous savez les pays
membres la réforme des retraites donc
emmanuel map macro ont déjà il épouse la
thèse de bruxelles de ce néolibéralisme
totalement fou et donc il va la mettre
en place
donc ils changent pas donc on parle le
gouvernement de combat mais en fait
c'était quoi avait un gouvernement de
plage
je ne crois pas je crois que manuel n'a
quoi il a toujours ce même cap mais avec
jean castex
il a un techno administrateurs qui va
continuer à imposer sa et qui va mettre
peut-être un peu l'huile de coude dans
les rouages
mais je crois que manuel macro c'est
vraiment sa réforme mère et ils se
moquent finalement d'aller contre les
français donc après ce qui va se passer
c'est qui aura la rue problablement qui
va s'affronter à lui les français et on
verra bien
et toute façon pour finir là-dessus
stéphanie je pense que la seule chose
qui pourrait déverrouiller la situation
s'est un moment donné de poser la
question aux français sur un référendum
de la réforme des retraites on me dira
oui manuel mais prend les prix à son
programme mais on se rend bien compte
qu'aujourd'hui la
hu a parlé depuis un certain temps il ya
eu le prix du co lead donc ça atténue et
bien entendu la révolte sociale
aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans
l'insurrection silencieuse et
municipales avec cette forte abstention
mais j'en crois qu'il pourra pas s'en
sortir emmanuel macron pour thème un art
au référendum mais pas que lui
d'ailleurs un côté la classe politique
depuis longtemps et je crois que c'est
la seule issue qui pourrait offrir lui
mais il ne le fera jamais vous savez ce
sont des il ya assez en rien d'un doux
rêve
ce référendum on vous dit ça va finir
dans la rue effectivement la cgt a tout
de suite annoncé une heure après la
réunion une manifestation et une grève
le 17 septembre prochain henri
sterdyniak ça va être compliqué pour ce
nouveau gouvernement de réformer
effectivement si déjà il ya cette
annonce à la grève pour le 17 septembre
on est reparti comme avant
alors qu'on nous promettait des
changements n'est reparti pire qu'avant
vous avez vu que la cfdt a pris ses
distances vis-à-vis du gouvernement et
la cfdt a dit tout à fait clairement à
monsieur castex vous ne vous êtes pas du
tout dans dans le voteront pour votre
histoire de ces frais pour vraiment pas
le moment
incident s'il ya des indes et des plans
sociaux
s'il ya chômage des jeunes augmente on
va pas faire une réforme des retraites
avec que ça suppose de d'augmentation de
report de l'âge de la retraite est ce qu
est ce que cela suppose au niveau des
négociations avec les branches qui
visiblement on a autre chose à faire
des entreprises qui sont en difficulté
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour ces entreprises et donc monsieur
castex il a loupé cette veut dire il a
loupé son rendez vous on attendait des
propositions précises sur la question
clé aujourd'hui qui est la question de
l'emploi et on peut rajouter comme la
fin de ce match est la question de la
revalorisation des emplois le premier de
corvée les gens qui se sont révélés
indispensable pendant la crise et qui
ont des salaires complètement ridicule
c'est une question importante
remettre en cause actuellement la
distribution des revenus en france
et là la pression les l'impression que
fait subir la la finance
il faut revaloriser les les bas salaires
t il faut une grande politique axée sur
l'emploi la question des retraites c'est
c'est pas c'est pas un sujet que pas
actuellement brandir les 30 milliards de
déficit des retraites en oubliant que
grosso modo il ya 200 milliards de
déficit de l'ensemble des finances
publiques et que de toute façon ça sera
on peut l'espérer résorber en partie
l'année prochaine alors effectivement
laurent berger le disait la priorité
c'est l'emploi est les syndicats voilà
qui accusait le gouvernement de faire un
chantage avant pour l'allongement du
temps de travail la baisse des salaires
l'activité réduite pour le maintien en
emploi
je cite le gouvernement met en avant son
arsenal pour détruire massivement les
emplois nicolas vidal effectivement
c'est pas un bon signal on parle tous
les jours des plans de suppressions avec
les manifestations hier chez airbus chez
objets chez nokia maintient gouvernement
ne prend pas la mesure à huit mois de
pause qui prend la mesure ce qu'ils sont
homos qui a une feuille de route je
voulais dit tout à l'heure il ya une
feuille route qui suit jean castex et
finalement il va fluidifier sa
nomination va fluidifier ce plan ce plan
néolibéral parce que pour moi c'est un
plan néolibéral ont pas au passage
d'ailleurs il faudrait peut-être que
jean castex occulte de la région ile de
france parce qu'ils n'arrivent plus à
payer la ratp la sncf
ça serait peut-être bien d'avoir des
priorités aussi dans la vie mais et
d'ailleurs vous savez les la majorité ce
n'est les plateaux des nouveaux
concurrents sont toujours en train ça
fait simone nous explique la réforme des
retraites
à première vue c'est très simple mais
personne n'en veut une majorité de
français ne veulent pas et puis après on
met toujours en passe vous savez on
pourra plus payer les cotisations pourra
plus qu'on pourra plus payer les
retraites dans ce moment je rappellerai
quand même qu'il ya des enquêtes qui
sont sortis notamment de yannick cargo
at et de denis robert
en 2019 sur l'évasion fiscale qu'ils ont
estimés à 100 milliards vous avez aussi
une fraude sociale carte vitale qui a à
peu près de 30 milliards selon le
magistrat sur le prat
donc si on veut aller chercher de
l'argent il ya si on va laisser de
combler certains déficits je pense qu'à
des mesures à prendre mais finalement
c'est une réforme idéologique la réforme
des retraites c'est une réforme
idéologique dictées par bruxelles jeudi
dire mais c'est comme ça on a perdu nos
souverainetés donc on va chercher à
bruxelles ses jambes pour faire baisser
les dépenses publiques maximum peu
importe l'emploi pas parler de
localisation peu importe ça d'ailleurs
bruno le maire ne fait que suggérer
susurré conseiller mais il n'aime pas
jamais rien voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui
henri sterdyniak effectivement nicolas
vidal met le doigt sur un point
important il faut quand même trouver de
l'argent effectivement pour notamment
relancer l'économie financer toutes les
dépenses publiques qui ont été faites
notamment pendant cette crise
ou est ce qu'on le trouve jusqu'à prix
on le trouve sans problème
il ya la bce qui est fait pour ça le
problème c'est que avec la crise le
gouvernement a soutenu massivement les
ménages est aussi les entreprises
on s'est endettée massivement sur les
marchés financiers on a été aidé par la
bce les taux d'intérêt actuellement sont
très bas donc il n'y a pas de problème
pour trouver des sommes importantes
on sent des donc je le répète à des taux
extrêmement faible il faut pas mettre
l'accent sur les 30 milliards de déficit
des retraites en oubliant qu'il ya 200
milliards de déficit de l'ensemble du
des finances publiques qui est en partie
sera désormais l'année prochaine parce
que là l'activité va automatiquement
reprendre lorsque le confinement pas
lorsque le confinement pas baissé ce qui
est très important c'est qu'il faut pas
que durant dix ans la protection sociale
très de déficit qui a le terrain qui a
été acquis si on peut dire en 2020 et ça
ça ne risque le risque l'année prochaine
on va dire au sommaire il faut diminuer
vos prestations parce que l'unedic est
importante on va dire il faut diminuer
les retraites parce que les le système
des retraites est en déficit et ça c'est
totalement inacceptable
il faut que les déficits de la
protection sociale a pris en charge par
l'état et que comme l'a dit mon collègue
il faut s'en prendre à l'évasion fiscale
à l'optimisation fiscale et
et aussi aux inégalités de revenus et à
la financiarisation
merci nicolas vidal et henri sterdyniak
d'avoir été avec nous en direct eu rt
france dans quelques instants
va-t-on devoir travailler plus justement
pour reconstruire l'économie on reste
dans les mêmes thèmes laminée par le
commis 19 que nous en parlerons avec
l'économiste jacques sapir puis
direction les états unis le président
américain donald trump souhaite faire
révoquer les visas des étudiants
étrangers qui suivent des cours en vidéo
conférence à cause de la crise du
commune
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression pour moi
l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique des technocrates les
activistes et de nombreux journalistes
ne s'intéressent qu'à la partie qui va
dans leur sens et censure ou dévalorise
le reste fonds décide de ce que le
peuple doit penser
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
sa cuisine et je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'avec une
équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour nous
pour nos fournisseurs pour nos équipes
c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le plus tôt
possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors par mois elle
s'était d'abord je voudrais vous poser
justement délirer autour d'un dessert
que j'ai appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde à man
[Musique]
et
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez 20h30 heure de
paris faudra-t-il travaillait plus pour
reconstruire l'économie laminée par le
cos vite 19 au fil de ses interventions
emmanuel macron semble le penser mais
n'y at-il pas un paradoxe a demandé aux
français de travailler plus alors que le
chômage monte lui en flèche
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en duplex de
nos studios de caumartin bonsoir jacques
bonsoir c'est petit alors jacques le
président macron a récemment rappelé que
les français étaient parmi ceux en
europe qui travaillait le moins que
faut-il penser de son injonction à
travailler plus stéphanie c'est
effectivement en effet ce de lieux
communs qui a repris le président macron
les français travailleraient moins que
leurs voisins et surtout moins longtemps
que nos voisins ce n'est pas exactement
ce que disent des chiffres par ailleurs
on peut se demander si le problème n'est
pas que les français travaillent peut
être mieux qu'un certain nombre d'autres
et puis la troisième question c'est
évidemment celle du rapport avec la
montée du chômage que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui est ce que ça a vraiment un
sens de dire qu'il faut travailler plus
quand on a de plus en plus de chômeurs
jacques qu'en est il des chiffres alors
stéphanie vous savez l'oscd ne tient
justement des statistiques régulièrement
sur cette question et on voit que les
français qui sont connus pour bénéficier
effectivement des 35 heures
1 un certain nombre de congés payés et
bien c'est français il travaille
beaucoup regardé justement ces
statistiques
vous voyez les français travaillent plus
que les allemands que les néerlandais
vous savez ces gens de l'europe du nord
que l'on dit justement très travailleur
banon les français travaillent plus
par contre il travaille peut-être un
petit peu moins que les italiens ou les
espagnols alors jacques
qu en est-il au sein de la population
française alors vous avez tout à fait
raison de poser cette question stéphanie
parce qu'on voit bien que suivant les
professions la durée du travail varie
beaucoup
prenons par exemple le cas des
agriculteurs les agriculteurs
travaillent pratiquement 60 heures par
semaine
les professions libérales les artisans
les petits chefs d'entreprises
travaillent eux aussi beaucoup bon même
les ouvriers et les employés travaillent
sensiblement plus que 35 heures par
semaine
donc il faut comprendre que 35 heures
c'est une durée légale mais que la durée
réelle du travail
elle est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
proche de 40 heures alors junte est-il
vrai comme l'affirment emmanuel macron
que les français travaillent moins
longtemps sur l'ensemble de leur
carrière
alors ça c'est fini ça pose la question
de ce qu'on appelle le taux d'activité
pour la tranche d'âge de 55 à 64 ans et
là encore l' ocde tient des statistiques
qui sont particulièrement précises
si vous regardez les chiffres vous
constatez que les français sont un peu
de choses près au même niveau que
justement les italiens les espagnols
par contre il ya effectivement quelques
pays en particulier la des pays d'europe
du nord comme les pays bas ou
l'allemagne où ce taux d'activité est
plus élevé alors comment expliquez vous
cela
et bien en réalité stéphanie ce que l'on
voit là c'est tout simplement l'effet du
chômage en effet et le chômage on le
sait il touche soit les jeunes qui
rentrent sur le marché du travail et
qu'il n'arrive pas justement à rentrer
sur le marché du travail soient les plus
de 50 ans où les plus de 55 ans qui sont
parmi les premiers qui sont licenciés et
c'est très exactement ce qui fait la
différence aujourd'hui entre la france
et des pays comme les pays bas ou
l'allemagne
c'est l'importance du chômage en france
qui pousse les entreprises
justement à licencier ou à pousser vers
des mises à la retraite anticipée tous
les personnels qui ont plus de 55 ans il
devient en france extrêmement dur de
trouver du travail quand
est considéré comme un travailleur
seniors alors nous voilà ramener au
problème du chômage d'où notre question
de départ dans un pays qui a plus de 11
% de chômeurs suivant l insee est ce que
cela a un sens de dire aux gens
justement qu'il faut travailler
davantage
évidemment non stéphanie évidemment non
si vous voulez le problème c'est que si
on veut que les jambes de plus de 55 ans
travaille plus et travaillent plus
longtemps surtout il faut leur donner du
travail
or nous sommes justement dans une
situation que celle inverse où il y a
moins de travail pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui les entreprises elle parle
de quoi elle parle de plans sociaux
elle parle de licencier pas d'embauché
donc on voit très bien il n'y a pas de
sens à dire il faut travailler plus
longtemps alors oui si l'on pose
peut-être la question de manière un peu
différente
alors justement quelle signification
pardon jacques j'étais impatiente de
savoir quelles significations cachées
tout est fait et vous aviez raison
d'être impatient parce que qu'est-ce qui
va se jouer par exemple admettons que de
par la loi
on repousse la durée légale du travail à
65 ans à 66 ans c'est pas pour autant
que les gens vont travailler plus en
fait
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui sera mis au
chômage à 60 61 62 63 ans
et bien il ne touchera pas sa retraite
complète
il aura ce qu'on appelle une décote et
on peut se demander si ce n'est pas cela
que vise en réalité
emmanuel macron autrement dit non pas
faire travailler plus les gens il n'en a
pas les moyens
puisque nous sommes dans une situation
où le chômage augmente mais bien de
diminuer les pensions de retraite
l art en conclusion jacques à vous
pensez que c'est
la seule raison alors c'est en tous les
cas la seule raison qui serait rationnel
mettons de côté évidemment la
possibilité que ce ne soit qu'un thèmes
idéologiques la seule raison qui
aujourd'hui est rationnel c'est que le
gouvernement veut faire baisser les
pensions de retraite il veut en réalité
finir de mettre en oeuvre cette fameuse
réforme des retraites qu'il a dû
interrompre le temps de l'épidémie du
coup vite 19 et que ce soit emmanuel
macron par exemple dans son interview à
la presse quotidienne régionale
où que ce soit jean castex les deux ont
dit qu'ils voulaient la reprendre en
réalité on voit bien ce qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui c'est une baisse des
pensions de retraite et bien jacques si
on comprend bien il va falloir se
retrousser les manches
merci à vous et à bientôt sur rt france
le torchon brûle entre donald trump et
les universités américaines le président
américain fustigé la célèbre faculté
harvard qui donne ses cours en ligne
pour protéger élèves et enseignants de
la pandémie kobe 19
il veut aussi révoqué les visas des
étudiants étrangers
dans le même temps les grandes écoles
contre attaque en portant plainte contre
le gouvernement américain les précisions
à dylan a fait radiant rien ne va plus
entre donald trump et les universités
américaines les prestigieuses facultés
de harvard et du massachussetts
institute of technology ont en effet
déposé une plainte au civil devant le
tribunal fédéral de boston
une plainte qui vise directement le
ministère de la sécurité intérieure et
la police de l'immigration et des
douanes
pour rappel donald trump avait affirmé
qu'il souhaitait une réouverture des
classes dès l'automne le président
américain souhaite également annulé les
visas des étudiants étrangers
si les cours contre st intégralement
virtuel une prise de position qui fait
suite à la décision d'harvard d' de
proposer ces cours exclusivement sur
internet à la rentrée
ridicule pour donald trump j'ai vu que
l'université d'harvard d'annoncer
qu'elle fermait pour la saison
pour cette année je trouve ça ridicule
je pense que c'est une issue facile et
je pense qu'il devrait avoir honte d'eux
mêmes c'est ce qu'on appelle la solution
facile
nous voulons que nos écoles soit ouverte
à l'automne un avis bien loin d'être
partagé par le président de l'université
d'harvard qui dénonce lui une décision
arbitraire l'ordre est tombé sans
préavis
sa cruauté n'est surpassée que par son
imprudence nous pensons que c'est une
mauvaise politique publique et nous
pensons qu'elle est illégale
nous défendrons ce dossier avec
détermination afin de permettre à nos
étudiants étrangers et aux étudiants
étrangers de toutes les universités du
pays de continuer leurs études sans
risquer d'être expulsé pour les
universités cette décision ne tient pas
compte de la santé des étudiants des
professeurs du personnel administratif
et de leur environnement il faut dire
que la situation ne s'améliore pas aux
états unis avec des dizaines de millier
de contaminations chaque jour sur un
total de 3 millions un chiffre
impressionnant auquel s'ajoutent
également 134 mille morts depuis le
début de la pandémie mais il faut le
préciser
donald trump ne ferme pas complètement
la porte aux étudiants étrangers qui
auront la possibilité d'être transférés
vers d'autres universités où
l'enseignement aura lieu sur place et
non en ligne mais à quelques semaines de
la rentrée
la majorité des étudiants risquent de se
retrouver bloqué et surtout expulsé
rentrer à la maison ça fait loin
beaucoup de gens ne peuvent pas faire
ces plans car ils n'ont pas d'endroit où
rentrée car ils sont adultes et qui sait
quelle est leur situation ou bien nous
rentrons à la maison chez nos parents et
c'est juste que c'est beaucoup demander
tout le monde est très inquiet car nous
avons tous une voiture une assurance
nous avons toute notre vie ici
pour rappel harvard et le m haïti
comptabilisent à eux seuls environ 9000
étudiants étrangers sur plus d'un
million à travers le pays
un chiffre qui représente une manne
importante pour l'économie américaine
étant donné les frais de scolarité
élevés des étudiants internationaux plus
de 44 milliards de dollars en 2018
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
de new york avec caleb mot par un
journaliste politique
rt america c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir calais maupin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors que
recherche le gouvernement américain en
tentant d'imposer la présence des élèves
en cours
donald trump c'est une façon d'essayer
de forcer lui la relance de l'économie
forcer les élèves à retourner à l'école
les parents à revenir au travail
les enseignants également devront se
rendre en cours donc c'est une façon de
pousser la rouverture de l'économie et
c'est une idée que soutiennent la
plupart des républicains beaucoup de
petits propriétaires d'entreprises sont
des soutiens importants pour donald
trump et ils ont l'impression que amazon
bénéficient de cette pandémie alors même
que les petites entreprises en souffrent
donc tonight rome essaye de relancer
toute l'économie et pas seulement les
écoles alors pour pouvoir rester le
gouvernement tram demandé aux étudiants
de se faire transférer dans des
établissements qui reprendront
l'enseignement présentiel mais c'est
très compliqué à mettre en oeuvre pour
ses étudiants il me dit en effet donald
trump met une pression très forte sur le
système universitaire il veut que les
universités rouvre et il fait tout son
possible pour leur rendre la vie
difficile si elle souhaite rester fermés
[Musique]
ou la ministre de l'éducation américaine
lindsey vonn et riesch a des contacts
avec les milieux militaires est une elle
défend les privatisations et
souhaiterais qu'il y ait plus de
privatisations dans le système de
l'éducation et essaye également de
mettre une pression sur le système
universitaire public américain alors
dans ce bras de fer en intrants veut
aussi révoqué les visas des étudiants
étrangers ça fait partie de sa manière
de mettre la pression est là les
autorités les universités plutôt
américaine s'opposent carrément en
justice l'institut de technologie du
michigan et l'université de harvard
porte plainte contre donald trump parce
qu'il menace de leur retirer leurs
étudiants internationaux
s'il ne réouvrira pas les universités
dont 1 30 souligne à un sujet que
beaucoup de personnes ont déjà évoqué à
l'occasion notamment par exemple steve
banane le système des universités
américaines travaillent au niveau
international plutôt qu'au niveau
américain uniquement l'un des grands
stratégiste américain de la gamme froide
a dit que des personnes du monde entier
se rendait aux universités américaines
et que cela participe et de l'influencé
américaine le système universitaire
américain ne sert pas uniquement la
population nationale les seuils de
courtiser la population nationale est de
rassembler les plus grands cerveaux
internationale afin de développer leur
loyauté envers les idéaux occidentaux
afin de faire d'eux des sympathisants du
des états unis de retour dans leur pays
d'origine
certaines personnes plus centré sur
l'économie nationaliste pense que c'est
une trahison et que les universités
devraient servir uniquement les états
unis donc ton à 30 ces pressions sur
l'université et fait de ces étudiants
internationaux des otages et souligne
ainsi le nombre des vieux internationaux
dans ces universités alors de son côté
lui donald trump il dit
il dénonce une utilisation politique des
universités pour quelles raisons les
universités aux états unis sont plutôt
d'inspiration de gauche il n'a des cours
sur l'étude des idées de genre sur les
idées de race
on parle par exemple du privilège blanc
et certains professeurs enseignent les
parties les plus laides de l'histoire
des états unis comme l' esclavage par
exemple un camp conservateur néo
conservateurs américains a lancé une
campagne contre certains enseignants
qu'ils considéraient comme étant
communiste anti américain il y a
vraiment une campagne de très longue
haleine contre la gauche dans les
universités et donald trump s'inscrit
dans ce courant ainsi que beaucoup de
ses électeurs des américains de des
régions les plus conservatrices des
états unis voient leurs enfants leur
revenir avec des idées socialistes de
gauche après les avoir envoyées à
l'université et considère que ce ne sont
plus donc la même personne et ne
souhaite pas cela est ce que cette
nouvelle sortie du président américain
il peut avoir selon vous un poids dans
la balance électorale
tout à fait le système des universités
est très important aux états unis on
parle d'inflation de l'éducation il ya
beaucoup de plus de personnes diplômées
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant et la dette
des étudiants est également très
importante l'éducation aux états unis
n'est pas gratuite comme dans d'autres
pays
il faut s'endetter ou alors payer
directement et le système universitaire
et donc une partie très importante de
l'économie américaine la tête des
étudiants est un acteur très important
économiquement parlant
beaucoup de familles ont un enfant à
l'université beaucoup d'adultes prennent
des cours du soir afin d'obtenir un
diplôme ou un autre du col parce que
dans la trame s'attaque aux universités
il pourrait causer des remous très
larges en tous cas jusqu'à novembre
merci qu'est la demande pas d'avoir été
avec nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
merci à vous
washington et pékin toujours en guerre
diplomatique les sujets de discorde
entre les deux puissances ne manquent
pas les américains viennent de
sanctionner les responsables chinois en
ce qui concerne la situation des
ouigours hier c'était au sujet du tibet
regarder avec rania berrada c'est une
déclaration qui vient s'ajouter à la
longue liste de griefs de washington
envers pékin dans un communiqué mike
pompéo annoncé mardi que les autorités
américaines allaient restreindre les
visas des responsables chinois qui
empêchent les étrangers d'accéder aux
régions tibétaines
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
déplore une différence de traitement
entre les deux pays de façon regrettable
pékin continue d'entraver
systématiquement l'accès des diplomates
et autres responsables américains des
journalistes et des touristes à la
région autonome du tibet ainsi qu aux
autres zones tibétaines
les responsables de la république
populaire de chine et les autres
citoyens chinois bénéficient d'un bien
meilleur accès aux états unis
la réponse de pékin été immédiate dès le
lendemain les autorités chinoises ont
annoncé des limitations de visas à
l'encontre des responsables américains
elle la chine s'oppose fermement aux
mesures des états unis compte tenu du
mauvais comportement de la partie
américaine
la chine a décidé de restreindre
l'octroi de visas aux responsables
américains qui se sont mal comportés en
lien avec le tibet nous demandons
instamment à la partie américaine de
cesser immédiatement de s'immiscer dans
les affaires intérieures de la chine par
le biais les questions liées au tibet et
de ne pas poursuivre dans la mauvaise
voie afin de ne pas causer davantage de
dommages aux relations sino américaines
et aux échanges et à la coopération
entre les deux pays
le porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères chinois a par
ailleurs assuré que le tibet était
ouvert aux étrangers
il a rappelé que la province avait
notamment accueilli l'ambassadeur des
états unis à pékin l'année dernière la
diplomatie chinoise n'a en revanche pas
précisé quel type de responsables
américains seraient frappées par les
sanctions et dans quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons à de
gérald darmanin le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur qui sans vouloir se montrer
plus proche des forces de l'ordre que
les dernières déclarations de son
prédécesseur
et puis enfin selon un rapport de la
commission denquête il y aurait une
montée de l'islam radical en politique
nous décrypterons se bat avec nos
invités
[Musique]
pour air france
pour renault ce sont des entreprises qui
sont en jeu dirait en feuilles
permanente on va pas obliger les
entreprises hors contexte actuel à à
garder leurs salariés ça n'a pas de sens
ça fait longtemps que je soutiens une
dit d'emploi garantie c'est à dire on
nous propose un emploi
toutes ces personnes ont notamment
qu'elle retrouve un autre jeune
on n'a aucune vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines au lieu de dépenser des
milliards comme ça pour rien il faudrait
mieux les dépensés pour former les gens
et les replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
du dernier rapport du giec sur les
océans
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui conteste norouzi
personnes non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des climats tous et non ce n'est pas
rien à part il ya des gens qui ne sont
pas des chercheurs qui parlent que la
presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat le gars plus de débats
aujourd'hui il ya plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va vers un
brin par une catastrophe ou 20 vers une
vraie catastrophe et on est incapable
d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nous faisons but est l'ennemi
y'en a pas d'ennemis l'ennemi ceni
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans sa
cuisine et bac je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qui avec une
équipe de vaccins cuisinier au tour pour
nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
groupe d'avants il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver
on sait que ça allait me rendre plus
tolérante et ben ça m'a rendu plus
intolérant alors parfois elle s'était
imposée justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche
la bad bank je voulais vraiment montrer
que le monde d'après il serait aussi
dynamique et tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les logiques qui vient de
manquer le match ne commence en effet
par sénégal la chloroquine domaniale est
utilisé pendant deux décennies et des
décennies ça pourrait faire sourire les
sénégalais quand j'entendis il n'y a pas
de signes qui mettent en doute ces
protocoles
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
et
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette ré
industrialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail décent un salaire des songes
parce que le salaire qui permet de vivre
ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs parce qu'ici c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis fini
par renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
otis moi de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 9
juillet cérémonie à mérignac en présence
du tout nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin prononcé un discours en
hommage à mélanie lemay jeune gendarme
tué samedi dernier lors d'un contrôle
routier une allocution avec des mots
forts pour rappeler son soutien aux
forces de l'ordre
c'est un constat qui inquiète un rapport
sénatorial pointe la propagation de
l'islam radical en france la commission
d' enquête dédiée à ce sujet a formulé
44 propositions pour combattre ce
qu'elle appelle l'islam radical
polymorphe parmi elles la transparence
financière des associations cultuelles
la serbie et le kosovo parviendront ils
à s'entendre somme est parrainé par la
france et l'allemagne se tiendra demain
par visioconférence objectif mettre fin
au conflit territorial entre les deux
pays vingt ans après l'heure confirmées
et pour parler qui pourrait être troublé
par la récente inculpation du président
kosovar par le tribunal de la haye pour
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité
on le surnommait le liant le premier
ministre et candidat à la présidentielle
d'octobre prochain amadou gon coulibaly
est décédé hier après un malaise
cardiaque
successeur désigné du président sortant
alassane ouattara il comptait parmi les
grands favoris d'élection présidentielle
d'octobre prochain
[Musique]
gérald darmanin le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur
mérignac ce matin il a remis la légion
d'honneur à titre posthume et mélanie
lemay la gendarme tué par un chauffard
samedi dernier il a salué jeu suit
l'engagement professionnel sans faille
de l'agent des forces de l'ordre suite à
ce décès le ministre a tenu à afficher
également son soutien au gendarme
gendarmes
vous comptez dans vos rangs des blessés
nombreux des morts trop souvent la
nation connais votre sacrifice la
république vous vous dire que votre
engagement n'est pas vain et qui ne le
sera jamais au contraire vous êtes
l'honneur de la république est les
premiers pas de gérald darmanin on en
parle avec l'une des figures des gilet
jaune jérôme rodriguez
bonsoir j'ai rencontré guieysse merci
d'être avec nous en direct par téléphone
sur rtl france tout d'abord on imagine
que vous êtes plutôt satisfait du départ
de christophe castaner dans l'absolu je
dirais que oui c'est une première
satisfaction doublée d'une déception par
la suite c'est une déception pourquoi
lorsqu'on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons un nouveau vivre de l'intérieur
qui est par causes dites donc très
sécuritaire réalité sur la police donc
je pense que la répression aura eu notre
faveur mais sera beaucoup plus sévère
qu'elle n'a été sous l'ère castaner et
ce qui est quelque part dérangeant c'est
d'avoir un chef de la police qui
aujourd'hui va diriger les enquêteurs
qui enquête sur des présomptions de deux
degrés de viol ou autre chose de sexuel
sur la vie d'une femme vous dites ici il
ya une forme de conflit d'intérêts parce
qu'on le rappelle un pour les
téléspectateurs qui l'ignoreraient
gérald darmanin fait l'objet
actuellement d'une enquête un
préliminaire sur des accusations de vol
a souvent violent à son encontre pour
vous voilà il ne fallait pas qu'il soit
nommé
parce qu'il ya une forte de conflit dans
cette affaire non seulement il ya
conflit d'intérêts mais aujourd'hui où l
exemplaire l'exemplarité s'il vous plaît
si vous voulez de 2,2 d'un ministre qui
est vidé sur une enquête et qui
aujourd'hui dirige dirige une fonction
importante du gouvernement donc oui il
ya conflit d'intérêts et je pense que
c'est une mauvaise chose et ça donne une
nouvelle fois une mauvaise image de ce
que peut apporter le gouvernement alors
vous dites c'est un sarkozyste ya un
aspect très sécuritaire c'est ce que
vous pensez à priori ou voilà vous avez
entendu peut-être des réflexions de la
part de gérald darmanin qui vous
laissent penser que la vie se mettre
serrer davantage la vis va être tirée
davantage on est aujourd'hui sur un
phénomène où on ne parle que de sécurité
choses qu'ils ne faisaient pas partie du
programme de macron donc on voit
aujourd'hui
l'influente sarkozyste qui peut y avoir
au sein du gouvernement ne serait ce
qu'à l'échelle du premier ministre et
oui forcément quand on connaît le
discours de l'ancien président sarkozy
on va s'axer vers un régime beaucoup
plus sécuritaire et je pense que la
répression sera beaucoup plus forte
qu'une qu'elle n'a été et on voit
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
n'apporte toujours pas de réponse quelle
que soit la difficulté qui se peut se
présenter à lui c'est à dire qu'à défaut
de répondre aux citoyens français et
d'apporter une justice sociale et
fiscale chose qui est demandé
aujourd'hui par des citoyens en colère
on active d'autant plus la violence et
la répression c'est le schéma
gouvernemental depuis quarante ans quand
on ne peut pas répondre aux citoyens on
applique une répression laplink des
amendes on applique une certaine
violence au sein de ce qui pourrait oser
élevé la boi clairement qu'elle doit
être tel devrait être selon vous la
position de gérald darmanin dans le
dossier sur les violences policières on
sait qu'il ya un débat qui s'est ouvert
notamment autour du placage ventrale et
de la clé d'étranglement aujourd'hui
clairement vous attendez vous et vos
comparses gilet jaune kg et une prise de
position claire
alors moi la première prise de position
claire poursuit référente là tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis des semaines sur le
débat sur les violences policières
je pense qu'une mesure forte serait
celle de deux de mettre fin à l'igpn
c'est à dire de pouvoir laisser enquêter
un organisme neutre et à la fois en
partial sur ce qui peut se passer en
terme de violences policières hauts du
mois sur l' enquête pénale donc est
administratif fait partie du ressort de
la police nationale il n'a eu d'enquêté
sur l'enquêté pénale
il faut aujourd'hui l'effet enquête est
un organisme neutre pour que la justice
puisse faire aujourd'hui la justice est
mal rendu parce que les différentes
enquêtes et les différentes pièces
apportées la justice ne permettent pas
de 2,2 m les responsabilités aux
policiers qui font des déviances
policière donc ça se ferait une mesure
forte a rapporté îlots mise de
l'intérieur aurait assez de cran pour le
rendre rendre justice à l'ensemble des
personnes qui sont décédées sous les
coups de la police ou qui ont été
malheureusement mutilé assure un aspect
plus aussi alain 22 novembre 2019 en
pleine manifestation des jd jaune crise
des gilets jaunes à voulant montrer
plutôt de la compassion avec ce
mouvement gérald darmanin alors ministre
du budget avait affirmé qu'on ne pouvait
pas dîner à paris à moins de 100 euros
par personne
120 at-il écrit bon de préciser c'est
une déclaration qui vous inquiète
aujourd'hui ça ne m'inquiète pas parce
que ça ne prouve que la déconnexion
aujourd'hui de dunes vélique
gouvernementale simplement je veux dire
moi je mangeais % var surpris en corolle
je mange pas pour se revoir les notions
paris parce que je serai puisque j ai
donc on vit pas dans le même monde
confie pas dans le même monde et on l'a
bien au prix on l'a bien compris en tout
cas de la part des gens qui nous
dirigent aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui on a clairement vu
jean castex reprendre le dossier des
retraites à bras le corps
la rentrée s'annonce compliquée
déjà le moment d gilet jaune est ce que
vous avez prévu déjà des manifestations
des rassemblements pour septembre alors
écoutez pour le coup c'est la question
qu'on me pose le plus aujourd'hui quand
j'ai l'occasion de me promener dans la
rue ou de faire quelques courses là plus
la plus la plus impressionnante des
discussions que j'ai pu avoir avec deux
policiers qui sont venus me voir et qui
nous ont salué qui m'ont demandé alors
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer quand elle
tombe est ce que vous pourrez reprendre
et la réponse a été la suivante
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ne faut pas
avoir peur des gilet jaune
pourquoi parce que le gilet jaune
connaissent la misère déjà depuis des
années et ça parce que c'est la misère
donc un peu plus elle sera beaucoup plus
douloureuses mais aujourd'hui vous allez
avoir des gens qui vont arriver en
septembre dans une misère qui n'ont
jamais connu et qui n'ont jamais eu je
dirais la ma chance de pouvoir la goûter
et c'est ces gens là qui seront
peut-être les plus dangereux quand ils
vont faire face à toutes les difficultés
qui vont se présenter à eux ne traitent
que celle du chômage pour pas oublier
que de multiples entreprises ont fermé
que des petits patrons eux ne seront pas
au chômage et ne reçoit bon rien et ce
seront peut-être eu les plus dangereux
merci beaucoup et jérôme rodriguez en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france un rapport alarmant du
sénat pointe la propagation de l'islam
politique en france la commission d'
enquête sur la radicalisation islamiste
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
toute la france sauf l'ouest est touché
par un islam radical
les parlementaires formule ainsi 44
propositions pour tenter d'enrayer le
phénomène les explications en images
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
et oui l'islam politique est un ennemi
mortel pour la république
oui il faut combattre toute forme de
communautarisme
[Musique]
oh
alors question y at il vraiment une
montée de l'islam politique en france
est l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
notre décryptage pour en parler nous
sommes avec frédéric un sinclair
éditorialiste ancien conseiller
politique de dominique de villepin
bonsoir frédéric saint clair à vos côtés
philippe pascot écrivain ancien
conseiller municipal everynautes
notamment bonsoir à vous également
philippe pascot merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france avant c'est un
sujet de société qui divisent les
français ce que j'ai délicat l'islam
encore pulsions prononce les deux mots
accolés l'islam politique mais de quoi
parlons nous exactement avant d'en
débattre et docti frédéric saint clair
alors écoutez le le terme islam
politique a été employée par le par le
ministre n'est pas le sujet du n'est pas
sujet du rapport c'est le sujet du
rapport c'est l'islam radical et le
problème c'est qu'il ya une confusion et
les politiques sont responsables de
cette confusion parce que ils ne
comprennent pas le sujet et malgré les
efforts répétés depuis depuis des années
de la part de toute une partie de la
classe intellectuelle pour essayer de
clarifier les choses bien il ya un
brouillard qui s'installe et qui fait
qu'on on mélange à peu près tout ce
rapport là est un rapport extrêmement
sérieux je suis malheureusement comme la
totalité des français incapables d'y
avoir accès puisque les rapports se
multiplient mais la population n'y a pas
accès vous rappelez probablement qu'ils
aient eu un rapport de la dgs si à la
fin de l'année 2019 la presse en avait
parlé
ce qui mentionnait 150 quartiers tenus
par des islamistes et ce rapport était
apparemment top secret classés
confidentiels aujourd'hui on a un
rapport sénatorial qui devrait
normalement être remis ou qui a déjà été
remis qui devrait normalement de
communiquer à la population et on n'y a
pas accès non plus donc on est en train
de parler de quelque chose que les
français vivent au quotidien
dans certains quartiers mais pas
seulement dans tout un tas de villes de
province mais qui n'a ri qui naquit
n'arrive pas à passer le filtre
politique pour revenir à eux et pour
savoir ce que enfin les politiques ont
compris ce qu'ils sont en mesure de
proposer comme réponse donc on est dans
une situation de blocage à la fois
vis-à-vis d'une seat d'une situation
sociologique qui est qui et enkystée et
puis vis-à-vis d'une société une
situation politique où le pouvoir
politique semble paralysée par un
phénomène qui les dépasse 1 philippe
pascot d'accord avec l'analyse de
frédéric saint clair ben il fut au moins
d'accord sur une future une chose c'est
que la plupart des politiques
aujourd'hui sont complètement dépassés
par ce qu'ils disent et parce qu'ils
font quand on parle d'islam politique ça
veut dire quoi ça veut rien dire
les gens qui parlent de ça ont
simplement peur compliquer leur pias
leur place
les gens qui se présentent en politique
et qui sont d'origine entre guillemets
de religion musulmane
c'est des gens modérés moi j'en connais
plein ccc saïda green hills et samir à
evry mais c'est des gens totalement
modéré qui qui en plus sont nés en
france et qui sont français
donc c'est quoi cet islam politique
c'est simplement des vieux politicards
compper compliquer leur place et que
trouve où cette combine pour les encore
stigmatiser une partie de la population
et faire peur aux gens mais il n'ya pas
d'islam politique il ya des connards
dans l'islam comme partout il ya des
connards en politique mais il ya surtout
des politicards qui veulent pas qu'on
put leur place quand on parle par
exemple la partie comme l'union des
démocrates musulmans même s'il s'en
défend ce parti a fait son fond de
commerce électoral de proposition liée
clairement à al islam est ce qu'on peut
affirmer clairement qu'il n'ya pas
d'islam politique quand on fait par
exemple préférence à ce parti qui fait
des scores dans certaines villes comme
maubeuge de très bons scores
frédéric saint clair oui donc sur
laquelle sur la question de l'islam
politique encore une fois mon propos
tenez à différencier islam radical islam
politique on parle pas de la même chose
il ya un islam culturel civilisationnel
qui lui est très présent en france très
près
en france et où les politiques sont
paralysés c'était le sens de mon propos
il ya effectivement un islam politique
aussi mais il est embryonnaire
le dmf donc donc que vous avez mentionné
commencent à émerger
il a changé son programme donc au virage
de l'année 2017 2018
le site internet a été modifié là le
côté républicain a été réaffirmée le
côté communautariste a été mis en
retrait donc le l'islam politique sert
la prise de pouvoir par des personnes
qui se revendiquent de confession
musulmane et qui ne s'adresse pas à
toute la population en tant que nation
mekhissi adresse sous un angle musulmans
existent
il est extrêmement minoritaire donc si
on multiplie les rapports simplement
pour cette frange de musulmans c'était
très bien dit qui pour une grande partie
d'entre eux veulent s'engager sont
musulmans et sont fiers de leur religion
autant que de leur pays et qu'ils ne
continuent constitue absolument pas une
menace pour le pays
à ce moment là on va perdre notre temps
en revanche le rapport de hakim el
karoui commandée par l'institut
montaigne en 2016 était extrêmement
clairs sur ce que j'appelle l'islam
civilisationnel il categorie les
musulmans en six catégories la première
catégorie 18 % ce qui fait à peu près vu
les chiffres qu'on a aujourd'hui du pew
research un million de musulmans qui ne
revendique aucune aucune volonté
d'exprimer leur foi dans l'espace public
ni halal dans les cantines ni séparation
en femmes dans les piscines ni voile
dans la rue donc ils sont intégrés
complètement à la fois au système
politique français nos systèmes
culturels 18%
les 82 % restants exprime une rupture
culturelle avec la france et dit les 28%
les derniers catégorie 5 et 6 sont en
sécession politique on a beaucoup parlé
de ce rapport lorsqu on focalise notre
attention sur la partie civilisationnel
culturel on se rend compte que la
volonté d'exprimer une culture islamique
est très répandue chez les musulmans il
n'y a pas de risque il n'y a pas de
guerre il n'y a pas de menace pour notre
santé pour notre sécurité physique donc
il faut arrêter de stigmatiser les
man il faut prendre du recul et regarder
réellement ce qu'on veut faire
la question est simple soit on veut en
france protéger la culture française les
traditions françaises et les moeurs
françaises mais à ce moment là il va
falloir que le contrat soit clairement
définie par le pouvoir politique
soit on ne veut pas et on veut mettre en
place une société multiculturelle mais
là aussi il faut s'adresser aux français
leur dire voilà le projet politique et
la yale société culturelle qui va se
mettre en place et vous allez devoir
partager l'espace public avec des
cultures qui sont différentes de la
vôtre
le problème ce n'est pas les musulmans
le problème c'est le pouvoir politique
qui n'a pas le courage de poser cette
question aux français et donc les
français ce christ parce qu'ils voient
leur environnement se transformer petit
à petit le jdd
oui le jdd il ya quelques semaines
enfin quelques mois a envoyé un
journaliste à roubaix roubaix cette
ville qui est très très prise par la
communauté musulmane
il écrit dans ces lignes on peut pas
qualifier le jdd de journal d'extrême
droite
il écrit dans ces lignes que le
supermarché le triangle affiches en
français et en arabe
les les inscriptions dans le supermarché
que la ville de 96 96 mille habitants
compte cette mosquée dont une salafistes
et qu'à l'extérieur du supermarché il ya
un tronc pour la construction d'une
huitième mosquée que les magasins autour
s'appelle l'aziza les mille merveilles
les délices du maghreb que houria en
sortant une commerçante voilées de la
tête aux pieds et que s'expriment en dix
ans ici c'est comme google
frédéric et ça on va on va redonner la
parole à philippe pascot dans quelques
instants mais je vous propose vous
pariez la réponse des politiques est
importante selon vous justement le
ministre le tout nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur a été interrogé sur ce
rapport du sénat qui pointent donc cette
propagation de l'islam politique écoutez
sa réponse aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale eh oui l'islam politique est
un ennemi mortel pour la république
oui il faut combattre toute forme de
communautarisme il me semble madame que
le miz intérieure est également le
ministre des cultes et qu'en français
cités ne veut pas dire la négation de
cette liberté des cultes
madame mon grand-père prier allah
et porter l'uniforme de la république
il m'a semblé que bien des tirailleurs
algériens et bien des supplétifs ont par
ailleurs tout en priant pour leur
religion défendu les valeurs de la
république
philippe pascot sur cette réaction du
ministre de l'intérieur à ce rapport moi
je suis effaré de plus en plus ces
braves gens font référence à leur
famille comme garantie de leur intégrité
soit il y en a un qui est née chez les
pauvres soit c'est l'autre qui était
chez les jésuites
ça va ça va d'un dad il a rien nous
apprendre ce brave monsieur il en train
de répandre la peur au lieu de s'occuper
des populations il en train de répandre
la peur et de créer du communautarisme
forcé au niveau des populations
moi j'écoute et frédéric et je suis très
content et je suis d'accord avec son
discours ce que je regrette une fois de
plus c'est comme il était conseiller de
villepin comment ça se fait que villepin
il l'a pas fait quand il était au
pouvoir parce que tous ces gens là qui
nous donnent des bons conseils ne nous
les donne que quand ils sont dans
l'opposition mais jamais des salaires la
majorité ça c'est un peu embêtant
oui frédéric laças claire va très raide
quand je le peux je ne peux qu'approuver
en ce qui concerne le discours de
monsieur darmana nouveau ministre vous
voyez qu'il ait battu complètement le
sujet central que j'ai évoqués il nous
parle de l'islam en tant que religion et
guy mon grand-père prier allah
ce n'est pas du tout sujet ouais la
liberté de religion est assurée par les
libertés fondamentales dans notre pays
on a le droit de croire en qui on veut
ou de ne pas croire et ça sera maintenu
l'islam politique c'est un problème dont
nous avons dit déjà en début d'interview
que c'est un problème mineur
la question c'est l'islam
civilisationnel qu'est ce qu'on fait de
notre culture de nos traditions de nos
moeurs darmanin le pardon gérald
darmanin n'aborde pas cette question là
il est fautif et je pense au regard de
ce que j'ai entendu lui à l'époque où il
était dans l'opposition sous françois
hollande
je pense que sont en multi culturelle va
le conduire à mener
l'exacte copie de la politique
multiculturaliste d' emmanuel macron
c'est à dire laisser prospérer cette
angoisse civilisationnel parce que les
français ne sont jamais amené à se
prononcer doit-on protéger oui ou non
notre culture si les français disent oui
il faut le faire et à ce moment là il
faut clarifier les choses et tout
interdire si les français disent non à
ce moment là il faut arrêter dans merde
pas redondant bekele le jul et puis
toutes les coupes dans ce rapport la
commission denquête veut créer une base
de données messieurs des élèves
scolarisés à domicile obligation pour
les associations de faire la
transparence sur leurs ressources en
particulier celles provenance de
l'étranger et la réactivation de la
police des cultes c'est justement
philippe pascot des points importants
c'est ces ressources qui viennent de
l'étranger tout de même
mais oui c'est un point important mais
excusez moi chère madame ce qu'ils sont
en train de raconter c'est encore du
pipeau il ya longtemps qu'on aurait pu
le faire et ils n'ont toujours pas fait
donc pourquoi il le ferait demain
donc ça c'est encore des effets
d'annoncé de dire qu'on va savoir d'où
vient l'argent
ah oui ça c'est pas la première fois que
je l'entends et c'est pas la première
fois qu'il ne le ferons pas parce que
l'argent qu'elle extrait de signes à
quoi maintenant ces volatiles ça vient
de n'importe où et quand on donne d'un
côté on reprend de l'autre c'est des
menteurs ces gens là maintenant le le
mensonge est devenu professionnel en
politique
ces gens-là nous baratine s'il n'avait
pas laissé des déserts dans les
banlieues je dis bien des déserts dans
les banlieues les extrémistes qu'ils
soient musulmans qu'ils soient de droite
qu'ils soient catholiques intégristes ne
serait pas rentré dans les quartiers
pour ce faire des familles
les vrais responsables c'est nous est ce
que c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui je
rencontre des gens qui sont depuis 30
ans en france madame 30 ans en france et
qu'il ne parle toujours pas français
est ce que c'est normal que dans les
arrière boutiques des restaurants ont
continué à embaucher des philippins qui
ne parlent que le philippin et qui n'ont
pas de papiers
est ce que c'est normal que dans le btp
on exploite des immigrés en laisse ou
payants et en s'occupant pas de widor
mais comment y vivent et comment ils
apprennent le français
les véritables coupes
madame du fait qu'il y ait d'une
extension des familles extrémistes c'est
le désert on a laissé chez ces gens là
on les a laissé croupir on les a
exploitées et maintenant on les montre
du doigt
c'est complètement inadmissible frédéric
ça car le mot de la fin
le mot de la fin c'est que je pense
qu'effectivement la la le contrôle des
financements qui viennent de l'étranger
est extrêmement important simplement
pour tout un tas de petites associations
pour tout un tas de deux personnes
privées les financements vont passer par
des canaux qui sont autres que les
canaux officiels
et à ce moment là le contrôle devient
beaucoup plus compliqué il ne réglera
pas comme l'a dit philippe parce qu il
ne réglera pas un attachement
aujourd'hui massif d'une partie de la
communauté immigrée d'une partie de la
communauté française de culture
étrangère à cette culture étrangère et
donc il va y avoir à un moment une
tension supplémentaire dans les
banlieues où les gens vont avoir
l'impression qu'à une stigmatisation
supplémentaire qui est exercée sur eux
parce que la république ne leur offre
d'un côté rien mais accroît la pression
sur la question financière est donc
cette tension va se se s'aggraver
jusqu'à ce que soit on se retrouve comme
le disait gérard collomb face à face
soit comme c'est la plupart des cas
chaque fois qu'il ya une tension de ce
genre là le gouvernement cède
merci beaucoup à tous oui on les arrête
arrêtons de montrer que les musulmans je
suis désolé il ya des extrémistes aussi
chez les catholiques
ceux qui s'enferment pour nous chanter
qu'en latin qui sont pour le moins qui
sont contre le mariage pour tous ces
gens là c'est aussi des extrémistes et
ils sont aussi minoritaire que le sont
les musulmans salafistes non merci à
tous les noms salafistes un mot les
musulmans salafistes c'est c'est 30% de
la communauté musulmane va en tout cas
ceux qui sont ces sessions politique
d'après le rapport d' el karoui
c'est chez ces gens là que se nourrit
aussi le terrorisme chez les plus
radicalisés on n'a pas de terrorisme
catholique en france
jusqu'à preuve du contraire merci à tous
les deux frédéric sinclair et philippe
pasqua d'avoir été
avec nous dont quelques instants rester
avec nous nous parlerons de la médiation
organisée par la france et l'allemagne
pour mettre fin au conflit territorial
qui oppose la serbie et le kosovo depuis
l'indépendance de ce dernier en 2008
puis la direction la côte d'ivoire où le
premier ministre et candidat à la
prochaine élection présidentielle amadou
gon coulibaly est décédé hier après un
malaise cardiaque
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression pour l'étude
démontre la nocivité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine au nom de la peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société
actis dont certains des employés ont des
qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates et activiste et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste on décide
de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
sa cuisine je me suis aperçu que c'était
bien plus difficile qu'ils avaient une
équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour nous
pour nos fournisseurs pour nos équipes
c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le plus tôt
possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver pensé que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et 20 ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors pas délirer autour
d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
principe même de notre association c'est
de réduire les inégalités d'accès à la
santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
21h30 heure de paris merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france
reprise du dialogue entre la serbie et
le kosovo demain une visioconférence
avec pour médiateur la france et
l'allemagne
objectif mettre fin au conflit
territorial qui les oppose belgrade ne
reconnaît pas l'indépendance du kosovo
autoproclamée en 2008 et reconnu par une
partie de la communauté internationale
les explications de monnaie à meaux dès
lors depuis des années les tensions
s'accumulent entre la serbie et le
kosovo
après maintes tentatives infructueuses
dans le passé l'union européenne la
france et l'allemagne ont décidé de se
poser en médiateur
une visioconférence est organisée suivie
d'une rencontre à bruxelles entre le
premier ministre kosovar
av du lao ti et le président serbe
aleksandar vucic avec ces pourparlers
l'union européenne dame le pion aux
états unis qui voulaient eux se poser
aussi en médiateur peine perdue ce sont
les européens qui reprennent les choses
en main une position qui n'aurait pas
déplu à donald trump
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle américaine
et pour cause le conflit qui oppose
belgrade à pristina est l'un des litiges
territoriaux les plus épineux d'europe
la serbie refuse de reconnaître
l'indépendance du kosovo proclamée en
2008 mais reconnue seulement par une
partie de la communauté internationale
et de l'autre côté le kosovo en cause
des restrictions aux serbes qui peuplent
majoritairement certaines provinces du
nord population qui se disent tant
primes et des problématiques colossal à
résoudre pour l'union européenne qui a
tout intérêt à régler ces différends
car il freine l'europe dans son élan
cette réunion va relancer les
discussions et le travail sur un accord
global et juridiquement contraignant sur
la normalisation des relations entre la
serbie et le kosovo portant sur tous les
dossiers en suspens aleksandar vucic le
président serbe arrive conforté par la
victoire écrasante de son parti du
progrès servent aux législatives de juin
qui le met en position de force et lui
ouvre une voie plus libres pour saclay à
la question très sensible du kosovo de
notre côté les consorts arrive avec un
handicap et pas des moindres
leur président hashim thaci ancien chef
de l'ofce qu'à la guérilla
indépendantiste est rattrapé par son
passé
le tribunal spécial a accusé le 24 juin
dernier de crimes de guerre et de crimes
contre l'humanité le chef d'état kosovar
devait justement se rendra à washington
le 27 juin pour un sommet avec la serbie
finalement annulé hashim thaci a déclaré
qu'il démissionnerait immédiatement si
les accusations du tribunal spécial pour
le kosovo était confirmée par une
inculpation formelle
un rebondissement qui ne plaît pas
vraiment en faveur du kosovo et pour en
parler
nicolas mirkovic cofondateur de l' ong
solidarité kosovo auteur du livre le
martyre du kosovo bon soir nicolas et
mirko vite merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors déjà comment
ça non ces pourparlers
bon on est dans une situation un peu
compliquée les deux parties donc la
partie et attendre et les représentants
de la partie sécessionniste du kosovo
vont se rencontrer pour la première fois
c'est la première fois que la douleur
coty le nouveau premier ministre va
rencontrer alexandre gucci sur la rive
en discuter sur ce sujet du kosovo
on sait que pendant pas mal de temps les
discussions ont été suspendues suite à
la décision d'imposer des droits de
douane sur les produits venus du kosovo
en même temps venant de servi au kosovo
en même temps il ya plus d'une quinzaine
de pays qui ces derniers ces deux
dernières années ont retiré leur
reconnaissance du kosovo
donc la situation est très compliquée si
on rajoute par dessus cela le fait que
hashim thaci soit possiblement inculpés
par le tribunal spécial pour les crimes
commis par les années pendant les
guerres des années 90 alors on est dans
une situation vraiment vraiment
compliqué et le fait que les états unis
n'aient pas réussi à organiser cette
réunion se met il ya quinze jours avec
la france et l'allemagne vont essayer dé
parvenir nous promet quelque chose de si
intéressant je pense que dans le dans
les prochains jours alors déjà la
question qu'on peut se poser pour
quelles raisons la serbie refuse-t-elle
depuis maintenant plus de 12 ans tout de
même de reconnaître l'indépendance du
kosovo parce que la guerre qui a été
déclenchée contre la serbie est une
guerre illégale l'oublier
que monsieur coûts seront à une forme
d'indépendance aujourd'hui et qui n'est
pas reconnu par l'ensemble des pays de
l'onu
c'est parce que que l'otan a bombardé
illégalement la serbie et a pris il y
avait une guerre civile dans en serbie
galles une partie des albanais qui
habitait le sud de la serbie qui
voulaient leur dépendance n'était pas
forcément la majorité des albanais je
rappelle que beaucoup d'abeilles qui
sont morts pendant la guerre étaient des
abonnés qui était fidèle à benton qui
voulait vivre en veau l'entendement avec
les cernes qui n'étaient pas des
ultranationalistes l'otan est arrivé à p
a choisi à former soutenu armés la
fraction aux militants nationalistes des
albanais du kosovo qui ont décrété du
genre ne manquent il y allait avoir un
pays qui s'appelle au kosovo imaginez
demain que la seine-saint-denis déclare
son indépendance de la france que le
limousin déclare son indépendance de la
france sans aucune base historique en
plus parce que au chrso si vous regardez
dans les livres d'histoire ça n'existe
pas un pays qui s'appelle le kosovo où
ça n'existe pas une langue que sera un
peuple que ce soit sont des inventions
de bdg aux politiciens de washington et
l'union européenne qui pensent qu'avec
des bombes ils peuvent régler des
problèmes et qu'ils ont inventé ce pays
regardez pas ce pays que factice qui 20
ans plus tard n'a toujours aucune
légitimité la russie ne reconnaît pas le
le kosovo pas plus que la chine
l'algérie l'espagne chi le vatican ne
reconnaît pas l'indépendance du kosovo
et je le répète plus d'une quinzaine de
pays ont retiré leur reconnaissance du
kosovo c'est une opération de
déstabilisation atlantiste pour
contrôler les balkans et on voit bien
que ça ne marche pas le kosovo a reçu
par tête d'habitant plus dead que
l'europe avec le plan marshall à la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
regardez où et et l'europe vingt ans
plus tard regarder où le kosovo le
kosovo est une des régions les plus
pauvres d'europe aujourd'hui c'est une
catastrophe
atlantiste et bruxelles comme washington
essaie de tout faire pour rêver pour
colmater la brèche mais là le problème
est bien plus profond que ça ça va pas
se régler juste avec quelques réunions
même s'ils avaient anglais merkel et
emmanuel macron les mettre leurs
meilleurs efforts justement et on voit
que c'est extrêmement compliqué pour
l'europe de régler ce problème est de
trouver une solution justement quel rôle
joue la france et l'allemagne dans cette
rencontre et quelles sont leurs intérêts
respectifs
l'allemagne est à la présidence de
l'union européenne en ce moment et donc
du coup je pense qu'elle voudrait
régler ce problème qui est un problème
important n'oubliez pas que le kosovo et
la serbie sont sur la voie de
l'intégration dans l'union européenne
que cette intégration impossible tant
qu' il n'ya pas l'unanimité des pays
européens or cinq pays européens
aujourd'hui ne reconnaissent pas
l'indépendance du kosovo donc du coup le
kosovo ne pourrait de fait jamais
intégré l'union européenne ce qui n'est
pas dans les projets de l'allemagne
emmanuel macron a clairement dit que lui
voulait régler ce problème
ils voient ça aussi comme une épine dans
le pied de l'union européenne et il a la
prétention quand même d'essayer d'être
une voix de l'état pour résoudre des
problèmes de de discorde en europe il
voudrait montrer qu'il est un homme fort
de l'union européenne et donc c'est pour
ça que c'est laid cette première réunion
se sont passées à paris à deux jours
avec avec un de leur outil aujourd'hui
avec alexander boudchich marre on veut
montrer qu'il est un homme fort et qu'il
est capable de régler les différends
entre pays européens
alors l'inculpation du président kosovar
par la justice internationale pour
crimes contre l'humanité
est ce qu'elle peut être de nature à
venir troubler ces négociations selon
vous mais bien évidemment
figurez vous que le chef qui a été
soutenu par des personnalités comme
bernard henri lévy comme des présidents
comme jacques chirac massimo d'alema
toulet l'establishement politique il ya
20 ans a soutenu cet homme comme un
libérateur comme la personne qu'il
fallait aller défendre parce qu'ils
étaient opprimés
parce qu'il était persécuté soi-disant
parle par la yougoslavie par belgrade et
on se rend compte vingt ans plus tard
que cet homme serait inculpé de crimes
de guerre de crimes contre l'humanité
les accusations contre lui sont
terrifiants par deux le kidnapping de
massat de torture et ça c'est l'homme
que l'occident a dépendu donc tout cela
apporte de l'eau évidemment au moulin
des serbes qui disent que depuis le
début c'est un groupe d'extrémistes
albanais qui ont sont soulevés qui ne
représente pas l'ensemble des abonnés
qui sont au kosovo que les attentistes
en décidé d'armer et de financer cette
personne pour pour qu'il arrive à ses
fins et qui ont inventé supplie dépôts
sont aussi la personne sur laquelle
s'est appuyée l'otan la france
l'allemagne les états unis pour créer
cet état factice est un criminel de
guerre
toute l'histoire du kosovo indépendant
s'écroule et ça obligera les instances
en panne et l'union européenne
les pays qui ont participé à cette
guerre à se remettre sérieusement en
cause parce que 6,8 ont pour crimes de
guerre ceux qui l'ont soutenu qu'ils
étaient dans les chancelleries allemand
françaises américaines sont complices de
crimes de guerre merci nicolas abi
cowitz d'avoir été avec nous et nous
avoir éclairé sur ce sujet merci à vous
c'est une disparition qui bouleverse la
campagne électorale en côte d'ivoire
amadou gon coulibaly le premier ministre
ivoirien est mort hier à abidjan il a
été victime d'un malaise cardiaque en
plein conseil des ministres
des hommages viennent de partout en
ondes fidèle bras droit du président
alassane ouattara
il était candidat à la présidentielle
d'octobre prochain
je rends hommage à mon jeune frère mon
fils amadou gon coulibaly qui a été
pendant 30 ans non plus proches
collaborateurs je salue la mémoire d'un
homme d'état de grande loyauté de
dévouement et d'amour pour la patrie
avec la disparition d'amadou gon
coulibaly la côte d'ivoire perd un
modèle pour la jeunesse
un exemple de compétences d'ardeur au
travail et d'abnégation que son âme
repose en paix décès inattendu et la
population ivoirienne elle aussi se dit
sous le choc
à 13h où je regardais dans un bureau je
regardais le journal et je remontais le
conseil des ministres j'élève même bien
vu
donc après moi je suis arrivé au travail
aux environs de 17h au moins un message
vous dit le premier ministre est décédé
10 mais c'est faux parce que moi mais je
le vis à présent donc je demande ça et
là
on nous annonce que les réseaux sociaux
qu'il est décédé a mordu de compte notre
faim
enfin il a l'a fait pour la nation le
candidat du rhdp
laisser reposer et surtout on attendait
ici pour parachever ce qui les attend de
l'autre on a fait vraiment ça nous a
choqués cette disparition rabais les
cartes de cette élection présidentielle
d'octobre pour en parler nous sommes
avec clément yao journaliste directeur
du magazine l'afrique aujourd'hui
bonsoir vraiment heroes merci d'être
avec nous on imagine que cette
disparition est vécue comme un séisme
dans la campagne présidentielle est
absolument s'appliquer sur le cassis bon
cd serbe assez brutale et inattendue
mais en même temps il faut quand même
mesurer dans que l'ampleur de cette
tristesse qui frappe toute la côte
d'ivoire
mais c'est amadou gon coulibaly était
effectivement mal à lire été admis en
france en phase d'hospitalisation qui a
duré pratiquement deux mois et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de polémiques sur
le tout à quoi tu vois or il qui était
annoncée à plus d'une fois et finalement
il est rentré mais malheureusement ou à
la mjc quelques jours donc deux points
soit 10 voix voilà que il décède après
une réunion du conseil des ministres
c'est vraiment un véritable choc au la
côte d'ivoire notamment pour son parti
qui est le président qui doit être
d'ailleurs candidat ou à la prison celle
d'octobre 2020 mais revenir sur cette
présidentielle mais on voit qu'il ya une
véritable émotion dans la population
qu'est-ce qui l'incarné monsieur
coulibaly en côte d'ivoire la jeune
génération mais pas que disons que bon
là dessus les avis sont vraiment partagé
c'est effectivement c'était elle et un
grand serviteur de l'état du corps dit
voilà c'est dire
ces postes de responsabilités notamment
au niveau du bureau national des travaux
qui d'abord de tout ce qui est un beau
double parle que de l'affairé bennett
n'était responsable ensuite la série
d'ailleurs 90 c'est l'été conseiller
technique du président alassane ouattara
au temps où il était premier ministre
ensuite bon il était à rassembler les
télécabines et celui des bons je la
termine en tant que premier ministre
faites moi un grand serviteur de l'état
de côte-d'ivoire
maintenant de là dit qu' il est vraiment
les candidats potentiels qui pourraient
donc continuer les lois soient tracées
sur ce point qu'il ya tout et tout
l'ensemble des débats puisque au sein du
pâtis donc tant qu'il dit il il
représentait le rhdp qui évoluera ce
rassemblement des houphouëtistes où la
démocratie et la paix qu il y avait déjà
les avis étaient partagés
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a poussé
certaines sorties c'est parti j'ai fait
allusion mais ces annonces en on
quittait donc les chefs de la diplomatie
il valait pas le passé qui est donc qui
a dû donc takla pas sorti du rhdp
voilà le 6 mai les avis sont partagés et
fit effectivement grâce et évitait de
l'état de côte-d'ivoire et c'était
surtout l'un des favoris à cette
présidentielle d'octobre est ce qu'on
imagine maintenant quelqu'un justement
sein du parti pour pour lui succéder on
imagine que c'est c'est voilà une double
perte pour ce parti qui était attaché à
lui et qui perd un candidat
effectivement potentiel favori oui oui
enfin voulu y aura du mouvement il
bénéficie quand même du bilan est jugé
assez positifs du président ouattara qui
est donc important et donc là dessus
c'est vrai est pas tendre si ce bilan
positif qui porte d'ailleurs qui en tant
que premier ministre la baisse était s
était davantage maintenant eux au niveau
des pays il a su que après l'émotion
les responsables de ces partis vont
penser à une pièce dirait changements à
l'ump des landes il faussement le
candidat qui sera désigné
je pense que moi mon analyse personnelle
le plaisir est rallumé finira pas y
aller parce que il n'a pas dit pendant
tout le temps qu'il a fait don il a fait
retarder donc on sont sa décision la
fille n'est parfait son choix sont si
son premier ministre
en même temps il était lui aussi tenté
voyez aller il avait même annoncé à
l'époque que si jamais eu se dessine à
gérer sa génération et est candidat cela
ne l'empêcherait pas d'y aller lui même
puisque la constitution actuelle lui
permettent d'une digue à quoi un
troisième mandat pardonnez-moi la
formulation de cette question mais à qui
profite entre guillemets un
politiquement cette disparition
justement dans la course à cette
présidentielle
mecelec civique serait scénique grador
c'est là que
et là moi de bons clubs elle profite à
pied ou alcool maîtrise yat-il que on
fait le constat que vick ego coulibaly
mme des plantes le candidat du rhdp qui
terminent quant à potentiel de ces
partis je vois pas d'autres
personnalités qui pourraient incarner un
peu tout ce que le 6 avril m ce
personnage
donc comme je risque de me répéter je
dirais que plaisant ouattara lui mais
c'est d'être tentés d'y aller parce que
à 2go coulibaly je vois pas d'autre
candidat qui pourrait donc se substituer
à lui merci beaucoup que les moyens ou
d'avoir été avec nous en direct de côte
d'ivoire merci on ira en irak à présent
le meurtre d'un expert en sécurité
spécialiste des mouvements terroristes
hicham el hachemi a été tué devant son
domicile ce lundi un homme engagé dans
la révolte populaire qui dénonce l
ingérence de l'iran et des états unis en
irak
sa mort a provoqué une vague
d'indignation dans le pays le premier
ministre a promis de retrouver les
auteurs du crime on écoute les analyse
un expert en sécurité et d'un
politologue
je pense qu'il s'agit d'un message pour
monsieur mustapha academy et que cela
n'a rien à voir avec la liberté
d'expression
l'opinion publique l'idéologie le
journalisme ou les médias
c'est un message politique fort pas une
protestation contre l'absence de liberté
d'expression
bien sûr que cela va affecter la
sécurité intérieure du pays
c'est un véritable test pour le
gouvernement de mustapha al-qasimi et
quant aux partis politiques ils
s'accusent mutuellement
la turquie est devenue le principal pays
acheteurs d'or de la planète en 2020
elle se hisse donc dans le top 10
mondial des réserves de métal jaune et
l'or constitue un rempart contre
l'inflation ankara tente donc de se
prémunir les précisions en images
[Musique]
la situation économique du pays est
difficile la dépréciation de la livre
turque a conduit certains épargnants à
rechercher la valeur refuge qu'est l'or
[Musique]
et en russie un haut responsable
politique arrêté pour meurtre sergei
forgan 50 ans gouverneur du craj de
khabarovsk
il est soupçonné d'avoir commandité le
meurtre de plusieurs entrepreneurs au
début des années 2000
sergei fogal membre du parti libéral
démocrate de russie formation
nationaliste est devenu gouverneur en
septembre 2018 il s'agit du cinquième
dirigeant d'un territoire russe a arrêté
au cours de ces cinq dernières années
trois ont déjà été condamnés pour
corruption ou crime organisé les
précisions de notre reporter antoine
claireaux à moscou oui sergei fogal est
soupçonné de meurtres et tentatives de
meurtres contre des chefs d'entreprises
dans des affaires qui remontent à 2004
et 2005 à l'époque il était lui-même
chefs d'entreprises dans les secteurs du
bois puis celui de la ferraille en plus
de l'arrestation du gouverneur quatre
autres membres du groupe criminel
supposés ont également été interpellés
toujours dans cette région de l'extrême
orient de la russie
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet la
porte parole du comité d'enquêté de la
fédération de russie
le comité d'enquêté le service fédéral
de sécurité de la fédération de russie
ont arrêté le gouverneur du craj de
khabarovsk sergei four galles des
poursuites pénales ont été engagées
contre lui suite à un travail long et
minutieux effectué par le comité d'
enquêtes ces dernières années et dont le
but était d'enquêter sur les crimes
particulièrement graves commis en 2004
2005 par un groupe criminel organisé
dans le crash de khabarovsk ainsi que
dans l'oblast de l'amour selon l'
enquête sergei furgala était
l'organisateur de tentative de meurtre
et de meurtre d'un certain nombre
d'entrepreneurs sergei four galles était
devenu gouverneur en 2018
un peu à la surprise générale en battant
le candidat de russie unie le candidat
du parti de la majorité
et avec cette enquête dont il est
maintenant l'objet vladimir poutine
risque très probablement de lui retirer
son poste de gouverneur d'après la douma
il était dans le collimateur de la
justice déjà depuis plusieurs années
mais c'est grâce à de nouveaux éléments
des témoignages en particulier qu'il a
finalement pu être inculpé une
inculpation que le principal intéressé
dément
on vient de l'apprendre il a décidé
finalement de
des non coupable aux chefs d'accusation
qui lui ont été présentés c'est
maintenant à moscou que l' enquête
continue afin de vérifier si d'autres
crimes n'ont pas été commis à noter que
dans cette région très éloignée de la
capitale russe son prédécesseur au poste
de gouverneur fait lui aussi l'objet de
poursuites judiciaires depuis 2000 19
mai lui pour des faits de détournement
de fonds et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans dix petites minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
ici on est cuit ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est pas interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
et
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
principe même de notre association c'est
de réduire les inégalités d'accès à la
santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tous met en place pour accompagner
dans la durée
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça faut ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui contestent leur
personne non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des climato sinon ce n'est pas rien à
part il ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
mais il ya plus de débat aujourd'hui il
ya plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers un vrai par une
catastrophe on va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on a incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimisme nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense que les communes guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons ville et les demis y
en a pas d 2000 ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types euros qui
vient de manquer le match ne commence à
sécher sénégal la chloroquine m'analyser
pendant des décennies et des décennies
ça pourrait faire sourire les sénégalais
quand j'entends des ménages il n'y a pas
de signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons quels rapports nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente le poids d une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
m
180 euros net en plus par mois pour les
soignants c'est ce qui ressort du projet
d'accord négocié par les représentants
du personnel hospitalier
gouvernement la nuit dernière dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé doit être
validé par les syndicats à mon avis pas
suffisant on certain collectif
quant aux médecins ils ont claqué la
porte des négociations la serbie et le
kosovo parviendront ils à s'entendre un
sommet parrainé par la france et
l'allemagne se tiendra demain à par
visioconférence objectif mettre ça en
conflit territorial entre les deux pays
vingt ans après leurs conflits armés et
pourparlers qui pourrait être troublé
par la récente inculpation du président
kosovar par le tribunal de la haye pour
crimes de guerre et contre l'humanité
bras de fer entre donald trump et des
universités américaines
le président américain s'en est pris
avec virulence aux facultés qui
dispenseront leurs cours en ligne à la
rentrée en raison de l'épidémie qu'ovide
pierre le pays à passer le cap des 3
millions de contaminations et déplore
plus de 130 mille morts liées au virus
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez c'est un accord
au forceps syndicats hospitaliers et
gouvernement ont conclu un compromis
hier dans les nuits dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé les détails de ce
projet d'accord avec notre reporter ben
hassen chébili au ministère de la santé
si les contours du plan massif en faveur
de l'hôpital sont désormais arrêter cela
ne plaît pas à tout le monde une dizaine
d'un tiers des hôpitaux de paris se sont
donné rendez-vous aujourd'hui devant le
ministère de la santé pour contester les
propositions du gouvernement en faveur
de l'hôpital public je vous propose est
d'écouter quelques réactions alors cette
mobilisation l'a décidé la semaine
dernière suite aux premières annonces
qui ont été faites par le ministre
concernant les internes qui était bien
en deçà de ce qu'on a ce qu'on espérait
et donc l'idée c'est de avant la fin des
négociations de montrer que tout ce
qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on a fait
pendant le creux vide il faut que ce
soit valorisée et notamment valoriser
par une augmentation de 300 euros net
par mois et ce qui nous a été proposé
ses 150 euros brut par mois et que pour
les premières années l'internât ce qui
peut et historique c'est la tenue d'un
ségur de la santé et
des enveloppes allouées qui qui font que
continuer à tomber et qui essaye d'être
plus essentielle sensationnaliste les
unes que les autres
mais là pour le moment en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les internes en médecine de
france là pour le moment nos attentes
elles sont pas qu'elles sont pas
remplies moi ce que je retiens c'est que
pendant que coville on a entendu
beaucoup de choses et je pense que
certains d'entre nous un certain espoir
qu'on allait enfin être écoutés que là
aujourd'hui en fait encore une fois on
nous manque de respect en nous proposant
par exemple la révélation des gardes
une réalisation qui est vraiment minime
puis à moins de 1 euros brut de l'heure
en plus pour moi c'est un manque de
respect après plus de six semaines de
négociations entre le gouvernement et
les syndicats dans le cadre de ce c'est
dur pour la santé hier un projet
d'accord a été présenté mettant sur la
table une enveloppe de 7 5 milliards
d'euros une enveloppe qui a été jugé
historique par le ministère de la santé
je vous rappelle que ce projet prévoit
une revalorisation socle de 180 aux nets
par mois pour le personnel hospitalier
or aux médecins une augmentation qui se
fera en deux temps à savoir 90 euros net
par mois à partir du 1er septembre
prochain puis 90 euros nets à partir de
mars prochain
ce projet prévoit également plus de
quinze mille nouvelles embauches
les syndicats ont jusqu'au 13 juillet
prochain pour donner leur accord
concernant cette proposition du
gouvernement et pour arracher digoit
infirmiers ses cheveux le challenge sur
cho soon et président du collectif inter
bloque les avancées obtenues lors de ce
ces cures sont largement suffisantes et
on est très loin du compte un le socle
de départ étaient des 300 euros pour
tous et et 180 euros pour nous c'est un
échec un échec du gouvernement est un
échec de ceux qui sont parties aux
négociations à nous représenter donc on
est on est très en colère les tous les
collègues issus de la base je peux vous
dire qu'il ya des réactions qui sont
unanimes et on est on est très très en
colère ce soir on va maintenir la
mobilisation et je pense que la rentrée
va être très très compliqué pour le
gouvernement la colère et la colère
monte ça va être aussi très compliqué je
pense pour certains syndicats qui sont
partis nous représenter et qui qui se
satisfont de base de cette avancée qui
n'en est pas une pour nous clairement
jean castex ne perd pas de temps entre
aujourd'hui et demain vont défiler à
matignon syndicats et patronat 14
rencontres au total début des entretiens
ce matin 8h30 avec laurent berger de la
cfdt
si jean castex veut reprendre les
négociations sur la réforme des
retraites ce n'est pas forcément le cas
des syndicats écouter ces réactions
prises la sortie de matignon on lui a
remis nos propositions sur l'emploi des
jeunes sur l'emploi sur le plan de
relance avec une volonté de concertation
on a redit qu on voulait une
concertation d'ailleurs qui associe et
le ministère du travail et le ministère
de l'économie et qu'on souhaitait un
plan de relance qui soient annoncées à
la fin à la fin août début septembre
qu'on voulait y participer on lui a fait
des propositions au terme de deux de
transition écologique de l'emploi des
jeunes il ya la transition écologique
bref on n'était pas tellement non plus
sur le fond on était plutôt sur la
méthode
là on a fait un échange aujourd'hui on
se revoit si j'ai bien compris le 17 ans
multilatérales ont valu précisé ce qu'on
lui a dit rapidement ce matin le régime
universel de retraite par points nous
avons suffisamment expliqué en long en
large et en travers
nous avons débattu avec les ministres
sur des chaînes de radio de télé
publiquement nous n'avons jamais été
contredit jamais mis en difficulté et le
gouvernement n'a jamais réussi à
expliquer et à convaincre de l'intérêt
du bien fondé de son projet donc notre
position n'a pas changé nous n'en
voulons pas et nous n'en voudront pas
donc on peut saluer ton très direct très
franches à dire presque rugbyman dans le
fait de passer un peu les finalement les
préliminaires on s'est dit les choses
il ya une volonté de dialoguer il ya une
volonté de concerter sur le calendrier
sur les sujets je l'avais entendu dire
par lesdits responsabilité et donc
juridique qui serait irresponsable de ne
pas traiter les questions d'emploi et
des bas salaires dans la période et que
c'était le sujet essentiel dans la
période et les salariés constatent que
plus le gouvernement donne de l'argent
aux entreprises
plus il ya de licenciement et donc c'est
ça qu'il fallait rectifier
bon j'ai trouvé que le premier ministre
était attentif à nos propos maintenant
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
c'était une réunion pour faire
connaissance pour échanger sur les
sujets d'actualité
en tout cas de notre actualité on verra
on jugera aux actes
écoutez l'analyse de nicolas vidal
directeur de la publication de putsch
médias et d' henri sterdyniak économiste
à l'ofce
c'est un monde des économistes atterrés
la réalité c'est que emmanuel macron
s'est débarrassé de leur fille pour le
sait tous mais il a nommé finalement ce
que j'appellerais un super directeur de
cabinet un emmanuel macron et jean
castex donc à ce côté vous savez le
peuple autophobie cet accent peu gersois
ce côté enraciné ce côté populaire ce
côté hommes des territoires jean castex
faut pas l'oublier c'est un énarque en
haut fonctionnaire magistrat à la cour
des comptes
donc un côté d'ailleurs le boss du medef
a parlé du côté rugbyman de de jean
castex mais moi je pense que c'est pas
pr ministre emmanuel n'a qu il a nommé
quelques qui va pouvoir mettre en place
cette réforme des retraites
c'est une fausse caution populaire jean
castex d'ailleurs je m'étonne toujours
qu'il n'y ait toujours pas eu le
discours de politique générale jean
castex alors que les débats l'assemblée
ont repris leur gouvernement donc non je
crois pas que les français attendent
vraiment la réforme des retraites et
donc mais une langue à ce texte et avec
emmanuel m'apprend romaine la table est
couvert tous et tout est prêt pour
repartir finalement dans un truc qui va
être intenable ramon à mon sens dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines mais les syndicats ont surpris
grandes préoccupations des travailleurs
actuellement en emploi
un certain nombre de plans sociaux il ya
le problème des huit cent mille jeunes
qui vont arriver sur le marché du
travail s'attendait à ce qu'on parle de
l'emploi qui se retrouve devant un
premier ministre qui leur parle des
retraites sujet qui n'est absolument pas
d'actualité actuellement on a un premier
ministre qui essaie d'utiliser le
déficit des retraites due à la crise
pour faire passer des mesures qui sont
absolument pas d'actualité
c'est pas quand il ya un grand problème
de l'emploi pour les jeunes qu'on va
dire qu'on va faire travailler des sous
102 64 donc naturellement les syndicats
l'on ne pouvait pas s'entendre avec ce
premier ministre gérald darmanin le
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur à
mérignac ce matin il a remis la légion
d'honneur à titre posthume et mélanie
lemay gendarmes tués par un chauffard
samedi dernier il a salué je cite
l'engagement professionnel sans faille
de l'agent des forces de l'ordre suite à
ce décès le ministre a tenu aussi
affiché son soutien aux jambes à
gendarmes
vous comptez dans vos rangs des blessés
nombreux des morts trop souvent la
nation connais votre sacrifice la
république vous vous dire que votre
engagement n'est pas vain et qui ne le
sera jamais au contraire vous êtes
l'honneur de la république
un plongeur andries cette nomination
risque de compliquer la situation en
france pour le gilet jaune la police
risque d'être davantage répressive on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur qui est
tard qu il est donc très sécuritaire
créé à l'écriture la police
donc je pense que la répression aura eu
notre faveur mais sera beaucoup plus
sévère qu'elle n'a été sous l'ère
castaner et ce qui est quelque part
dérangeant c'est d'avoir un chef de la
police qui aujourd'hui va diriger les
enquêteurs qui enquête sur des
présomptions de 2 2 me de gains de viol
ou autre chose les violences sexuelles
sur la vie d'une femme mais aujourd'hui
où l exemplaire l'exemplarité s'il vous
plaît si vous voulez 6-2-2 d'un ministre
qui est visée sur une enquête qui
aujourd'hui dirige dirige une fonction
importante du gouvernement donc oui il
ya une fille d'intérêt et je pense que
c'est une mauvaise chose et ça donne une
nouvelle fois une mauvaise image de ce
que peut apporter le gouvernement
leur reprise du dialogue entre la serbie
et le kosovo demain une visioconférence
avec pour médiateur la france et
l'allemagne objectif mettre fin au
conflit territorial qui les oppose
belgrade ne reconnaît pas l'indépendance
du kosovo autoproclamée en 2008 et
reconnu par une partie des communauté
internationale les explications de mona
hamou dès lors depuis des années les
tensions s'accumulent entre la serbie et
le kosovo
après maintes tentatives infructueuses
dans le passé l'union européenne la
france et l'allemagne ont décidé de se
poser en médiateur
une visioconférence est organisée suivie
d'une rencontre à bruxelles entre le
premier ministre kosovar
abdullah au ti et le président serbe
aleksandar vucic avec ces pourparlers
l'union européenne dame le pion aux
états unis qui voulaient eux se poser
aussi en médiateur peine perdue ce sont
les européens qui reprennent les choses
en main une position qui n'aurait pas
déplu à donald trump
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle américaine
et pour cause le conflit qui oppose
belgrade à pristina est l'un des litiges
territoriaux les plus épineux d'europe
la serbie refuse de reconnaître
l'indépendance du kosovo proclamée en
2008 mais reconnue seulement par une
partie de la communauté internationale
et de l'autre côté le kosovo en cause
des restrictions aux serbes qui peuplent
majoritairement certaines provinces du
nord population qui se disent tant
primes et des problématiques colossal à
résoudre pour l'union européenne qui a
tout intérêt à régler ces différends
car il freine l'europe dans son élan
cette réunion va relancer les
discussions et le travail sur un accord
global et juridiquement contraignant sur
la normalisation des relations entre la
serbie et le kosovo portant sur tous les
dossiers en suspens aleksandar vucic le
président serbe arrive conforté par la
victoire écrasante de son parti du
progrès servent aux législatives de juin
qui le met en position de force et lui
ouvre une voie plus libres pour saclay à
la question très sensible du kosovo de
notre côté les consorts arrive avec un
handicap et pas des moindres
leur président hashim thaci ancien chef
de loups checa la guérilla
indépendantiste est rattrapé par son
passé
le tribunal spécial a accusé le 24 juin
dernier de crimes de guerre et de crimes
contre l'humanité le chef d'état kosovar
devait justement se rendra à washington
le 27 juin pour un sommet avec la serbie
finalement annulé hashim thaci a déclaré
qu'il démissionnerait immédiatement si
les accusations du tribunal spécial pour
le kosovo était confirmée par une
occupation formelle un rebondissement
qui ne plaît pas vraiment en faveur du
kosovo elle selon nikolaï mirkovic
cofondateur de l' ong solidarité kosovo
auteur du livre le martyre du kosovo la
serbie n'est pas le seul pays de l'onu à
ne pas reconnaître l'indépendance du
kosovo
la guerre a été déclenchée contre la
serbie est une guerre illégale n'oubliez
pas que le monsieur kosovo à une forme
d'indépendance aujourd'hui et qui n'est
pas reconnu par l'ensemble des pays de
l'onu
c'est parce que que l'otan a bombardé
illégalement la serbie et a pris il ya
eu une guerre civile dans en serbie
gagne une partie des albanais qui
habitait le sud de la serbie qui
voulaient leur dépendance n'était pas
forcément la majorité des albanais je
rappelle que beaucoup d'abeilles qui
sont morts pendant la guerre étaient des
abonnés qui était fidèle à belgrade qui
voulait vivre en veau l'entendement avec
les serbes qui n'étaient pas des
ultranationalistes l'otan est arrivé à
fait a choisi à former soutenu armés la
fraction aux militants nationalistes des
albanais du kosovo qui ont décrété du
genre ne manquent il y allait avoir un
pays qui s'appelle au kosovo imaginez
demain que la seine-saint-denis déclare
son indépendance de la france que le
limousin déclare son indépendance de la
france sur aucune base historique en
plus parce que au chrso si vous regardez
dans les livres d'histoire ça n'existe
pas un pays qui s'appelle le kosovo que
ça n'existe en une langue que sera un
peuple que ce soit sont des inventions
de bdg aux politiciens de washington et
l'union européenne qui pensent qu'avec
des bombes ils peuvent régler des
problèmes et qu'ils ont inventé ce pays
regardez pas ce pays que factice qui 20
ans plus tard mais a toujours aucune
légitimité la russie ne reconnaît pas le
le kosovo pas plus que la chine
l'algérie l'espagne chi le vatican ne
reconnaît pas l'indépendance du kosovo
le torchon brûle entre donald trump et
des universités américaines le président
américain fustigé la célèbre faculté
harvard qui donne ses cours en ligne
pour protéger élèves et enseignants des
pandémies de kobe 19
il veut aussi révoqué les visas des
étudiants étrangers
dans le même temps les grandes écoles
contre attaque en portant plainte contre
le gouvernement américain les précisions
dylan a fait radiant rien ne va plus
entre donald trump et les universités
américaines les prestigieuses facultés
de harvard et du massachussetts
institute of technology ont en effet
déposé une plainte au civil devant le
tribunal fédéral de boston
une plainte qui vise directement le
ministère de la sécurité intérieure et
la police de l'immigration et des
douanes
pour rappel donald trump avait affirmé
qu'il souhaitait une réouverture des
classes dès l'automne le président
américain souhaite également annulé les
visas des étudiants étrangers
si les cours contre st intégralement
virtuel une prise de position qui fait
suite à la décision d'harvard d' de
proposer ces cours exclusivement sur
internet à la rentrée ridicule pour
donald trump
j'ai vu que l'université d'harvard
d'annoncer qu'elle fermait pour la
saison pour cette année je trouve ça
ridicule
je pense que c'est une issue facile et
je pense qu'il devrait avoir honte d'eux
mêmes c'est ce qu'on appelle la solution
facile
nous voulons que nos écoles soit ouverte
à l'automne un avis bien loin d'être
partagé par le président de l'université
d'harvard qui dénonce lui une décision
arbitraire l'ordre est tombé sans
préavis
sa cruauté n'est surpassée que par son
imprudence nous pensons que c'est une
mauvaise politique publique et nous
pensons qu'elle est illégale
nous défendrons ce dossier avec
détermination afin de permettre à nos
étudiants étrangers et aux étudiants
étrangers de toutes les universités du
pays de continuer leurs études sans
risquer d'être expulsé pour les
universités cette décision ne tient pas
compte de la santé des étudiants des
professeurs du personnel administratif
et de leur environnement il faut dire
que la situation ne s'améliore pas aux
états unis avec des dizaines
de millier de contaminations chaque jour
sur un total de 3 millions un chiffre
impressionnant auquel s'ajoutent
également 134 mille morts depuis le
début de la pandémie mais il faut le
préciser
donald trump ne ferme pas complètement
la porte aux étudiants étrangers qui
auront la possibilité d'être transférés
vers d'autres universités où
l'enseignement aura lieu sur place et
non en ligne mais à quelques semaines de
la rentrée
la majorité des étudiants risquent de se
retrouver bloqué et surtout expulsé
rentrer à la maison ça fait loin
beaucoup de gens ne peuvent pas faire
ces plans car ils n'ont pas d'endroit où
rentrée car ils sont adultes et qui sait
quelle est leur situation ou bien nous
rentrons à la maison chez nos parents et
c'est juste que c'est beaucoup demander
tout le monde est très inquiet car nous
avons tous une voiture une assurance
nous avons toute notre vie ici
pour rappel harvard et le m haïti
comptabilisent à eux seuls environ 9000
étudiants étrangers sur plus d'un
million à travers le pays
un chiffre qui représente une manne
importante pour l'économie américaine
étant donné les frais de scolarité
élevés des étudiants internationaux plus
de 44 milliards de dollars en 2018
quel est mon pain journaliste politique
chez rta america sa décision de donald
trump s'explique c'est selon lui une
façon pour le président américain de
relancer l'économie
donald trump c'est une façon d'essayer
de forcer à lui la relance de l'économie
forcer les élèves à retourner à l'école
les parents à revenir au travail
les enseignants également devront se
rendre en cours donc c'est une façon aux
deux pouces et la rouverture de
l'économie et c'est une idée que
soutiennent la plupart des républicains
beaucoup de petits propriétaires
d'entreprises sont des soutiens
importants pour donald trump et ils ont
l'impression que amazon bénéficient de
cette pandémie alors même que les
petites entreprises en souffrent
octo notre homme essaye de relancer
toute l'économie et pas seulement les
écoles donald trump met une pression
très forte sur le système universitaire
il veut que les universités erreur et il
fait tout son possible pour leur rendre
la vie difficile si elle souhaite rester
fermés
la ministre de l'éducation américaine
lancée des bosses et riche à des
contacts avec les milieux militaires et
une défend la privatisation et
souhaiterais qu'il y ait plus de
privatisations dans le système de
l'éducation et essaie également de
mettre une pression sur le système
universitaire public américain
washington et pékin toujours en guerre
diplomatique les sujets de discorde
entre les deux puissances ne manquent
pas les américains viennent de
sanctionner des responsables chinois ce
qui concerne la situation des ouigours
et hier c'était au sujet du tibet rania
berhad c'est une déclaration qui vient
s'ajouter à la longue liste de griefs de
washington envers pékin dans un
communiqué mike pompéo a annoncé mardi
que les autorités américaines allaient
restreindre les visas des responsables
chinois qui empêchent les étrangers
d'accéder aux régions tibétaines
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
déplore une différence de traitement
entre les deux pays de façon regrettable
pékin continue d'entraver
systématiquement l'accès des diplomates
et autres responsables américains des
journalistes et des touristes à la
région autonome du tibet ainsi qu aux
autres zones tibétaines
les responsables de la république
populaire de chine et les autres
citoyens chinois bénéficient d'un bien
meilleur accès aux états unis la réponse
de pékin été immédiate dès le lendemain
les autorités chinoises ont annoncé des
limitations de visas à l'encontre des
responsables américains elle la chine
s'oppose fermement aux mesures des états
unis compte tenu du mauvais comportement
de la partie américaine
la chine a décidé de restreindre
l'octroi de visas aux responsables
américains qui se sont mal comportés en
lien avec le tibet nous demandons
instamment à la partie américaine de
cesser immédiatement de s'immiscer dans
les affaires intérieures de la chine
le biais les questions liées au tibet et
de ne pas poursuivre dans la mauvaise
voie
afin de ne pas causer davantage de
dommages aux relations sino américaines
et aux échanges et à la coopération
entre les deux pays
le porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères chinois a par
ailleurs assuré que le tibet était
ouvert aux étrangers
il a rappelé que la province avait
notamment accueilli l'ambassadeur des
états unis à pékin l'année dernière la
diplomatie chinoise n'a en revanche pas
précisé quel type de responsables
américains seraient frappées par les
sanctions et analyse avec un jean
charles chang économiste et spécialiste
de la chine les américains remettent une
couche si j'ose dire
après laffaire de toute façon faut pas
oublier que tibet fait partie de la
boîte à outils que déjà met ko développé
depuis quelques années à savoir le tibet
le xinjiang ouïgours quoi pollution
on comble qui a été rajouté l'année
dernière et taiwan bien entendu qu'un
problème depuis toujours donc plein par
icm en somme n'est à réactiver le thème
avec du côté chinois une crainte bien
entendu que en réactivant une offensive
sur le tibet c'est des signaux qui sera
envoyée à des sécessionnistes et qui
viendrait compromettre éventuellement la
stabilité et la tranquillité dans la
région du tibet
et c'est une disparition qui bouleverse
la campagne électorale en côte d'ivoire
amadou gon coulibaly le premier ministre
ivoirien est mort hier à abidjan il a
été victime d'un malaise cardiaque en
plein conseil des ministres
les hommages viennent de partout fidèle
bras droit du président alassane
ouattara
il était candidat à la présidentielle
d'octobre prochain je rends hommage à
mon jeune frère mon fils amadou gon
coulibaly qui a été pendant 30 ans
mon plus proche collaborateur je salue
la mémoire d'un homme d'état de grande
loyauté de dévouement et d'amour pour la
patrie
avec la disparition d'amadou gon
coulibaly la côte d'ivoire perd un
modèle pour la jeunesse
un exemple de compétences d'ardeur au
travail et d'abnégation que son âme
repose en paix un décès inattendu et la
population ivoirienne elle aussi se dit
sous le choc
à 13h où je regardais d'un bureau je
regardais le journal et je remontais le
conseil des ministres j'ai les mêmes
bien vu donc après moi je suis arrivé au
travail aux environs de 17 heures on
m'envoie un message vous dit ne pas
miner c'est d'y céder les 10 mais c'est
faux parce que moi mais je le vis à 13
ans donc je demande ça et là
on nous annonce si les réseaux sociaux
qu'il est décidé à mort du taureau notre
ère
enfin il a l'a fait pour la nation le
candidat de leur expression possède
surtout on attendait ici pour parachever
la rencontre a fait le mans ça nous a
choqués 1 selon clément et au
journaliste et directeur du magazine
l'afrique aujourd'hui et mondou gon
coulibaly n'a toujours pas fait
l'unanimité dans son camp
il était grand serviteur de l'état de
quoi dit voilà c'est dire ces postes de
responsabilités notamment au niveau du
bureau national des travaux qui doivent
d'abord qu'est-ce que tout ce qui est en
mode double par codic rappelle bennett
n'était un responsable ensuite la série
d'ailleurs depuis 97 il était conseiller
technique du président alassane ouattra
ou temps où il était premier ministre
ensuite bon il était absent dans les
télécabines et celui des bons je la
termine en tant que premier ministre
faites moi un grand serviteur de l'état
de côte-d'ivoire
maintenant de là dit qu' il est vraiment
les candidats potentiels qui pourraient
donc continuer de l'isoloir à 100 watts
à la csu qu'il ya tout et tout est
rassemblé débat parce qu'au sein du
parti
donc tant qu ils doutent ils
représentaient le rhdp qui est drôle il
rassemble rassemblement des
houphouëtistes où la démocratie et la
paix il y avait déjà les avis étaient
partagés
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a poussé
certains à 100 que c'est parti j'ai fait
ma religion mais c'est à nos talons qui
étaient donc les chefs de la diplomatie
il va aller ou pas le passé qui est donc
il ya du donc takla pas sorti du rhdp
voilà le 6ème règle les avis sont
partagés une fille effectivement grâce
évitez de l'état de côte-d'ivoire
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité demain 7h du matin
excellente fin de soirée tout sur rt
france
[Musique]
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû revenir
les système de clip parce que cela
permet de développer de très grandes
surfaces à l'intérieur de tout petits
espaces ce n'est donc pas surprenant de
voir de l'origami dans les ailes
d'insectes et dans les feuilles dans
l'intestin
on peut même voir des systèmes de plus
elle semblable sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surfaces planes nous porte vers
la découverte d'un code universel de la
nature
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis au l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france le général budin
en fait été effectivement être un
condisciple d'impôt de l'impôt lui ment
brillait donc il est l'été l'école de
brienne en même temps en même temps que
napoléon s'est il est mort donc